seconds till you're all set to go thank
you
okay good evening everybody and welcome
to this evening's virtual meeting of
stratfor living
planning committee my name is councillor
peter richards and i will be chairing
the meeting this evening
before we start i've got some
housekeeping to run through if i may um
please note that the meeting is being
streamed live
and is being recorded for future
publication on the council's website
and on youtube members you'll have all
been provided with council's etiquette
for our virtual
meeting uh just to remind you of a few
of the salient points please can you
make sure that your device
is charged or charging
please mute your microphones when you're
not speaking and of course remember to
unmute them when you are speaking
if you could please indicate in the chat
when you do want to speak and i will
call you in
at an appropriate time if for any reason
you experience any i.t troubles please
do everything you can to
get back into our meeting as soon as you
possibly can
there is a number in the chat if you
have any problems with that
if you can't get back in you will have
been deemed to have left the meeting at
that point and we will continue provided
that we are still correct um i can
confirm
that checks have been made in front of
our legal officer that all members of
the committee can
see and hear or proceedings and they
have read all the salient documentation
and to introduce some of our officers uh
we have present online with us
liz daworska and olivia quinn from our
committee services we have ross chambers
who is our
legal representative and from our
planning department in a particular
order we have
charlotte dix louise casey amy flute and
joe brook
and our planning manager is tracy
humphries tracy i believe you have a
statement to me
i do chairman thank you yes i'm the
implementation team leader and your
planning manager tonight
and my role is to provide impartial
advice and to assist members in their
decision taking
thank you thank you very much and to our
public speakers
um we will only be able to allow those
that have registered to speak
to speak when you do come to speak
please press
star and six on your phone keypads in
order to unmute yourselves
we will then check to make sure you can
hear us and we can hear you
um that's star six to unmute um
if you could please turn off any live
streams that are going on in the
background while you are speaking there
is a minor delay between the live stream
and you speaking to us on the phone and
it does tend to interfere so please turn
off any
uh background noise and live streams we
have a lot to get through
and we do have to start our final item
by half past eight so please if we can
keep our questions and answers
concise that would be very beneficial to
us all
right let's get straight into our
meeting agenda first up is our apologies
for absence olivia could you please give
us some apologies
chair we've got apologies from
councillors adam and curtis
marvelous thank you very much um
disclosures of interest please members
if you could indicate in the chat if you
have any disclosures
i will go first while uh while
everyone's popping those in the chat so
um application number twenty zero zero
one three one full snitchfield sports
club i am the ward member and i've
registered to speak so i will step away
from the committee for that
and councillor fleming will take over
the chair for that
item um i believe also we have all
received
an email with photos and some text on
application 203354
ful which is new house farm uh on
birmingham road
um uh councillor parry please thank you
good evening chair and good evening
fellow councillors
um i'd just like to disclose an interest
i'm county councillor for the
snitterfield
um award but i'm really quite happy to
speak because i haven't been involved in
any of the discussions on that
particular
application and i'd also like to
disclose an interest
um for application number 24
03395
the agricultural building at butler's
marston
um i do know the applicants not terribly
well but
certainly have dealt with the applicants
um
as uh in a in a professional capacity
um i don't believe um that has any
bearing on the application in front of
me
so i come with an open mind but i just
wanted to highlight those points
thank you lovely lovely thank you very
much counselor eden please
come on i'm mute you are unmuted
good now you're remuted
technology technology is a joy we'll
come back to you uh counselor ed and uh
councillor chrome i've got it i've got
it
go ahead sorry jet um different laptop
tonight um
just to declare an interest i'm the ward
member for halt road studly that's two
zero slash zero three one two three
uh and i'll be speaking on that one
marvelous thank you councillor crump
yeah thank you mr chairman and welcome
uh
hello to everybody tonight yeah land at
penndot street
item number seven twenty zero two
five eight zero slash full i'm the ward
member
i will be speaking on and will be
stepping away from the committee for
that item thank you
marvelous thank you councillor henry
seraphin
ah thank you chair yeah an interest
that's uh
on the application 20 stroke 0
3 1 2 3. um i know the speakers
who are speaking on their opposition to
this planning application but
i come to this application with an open
mind
thank you very good thank you very much
um councilman mills do you have one
yes mr chairman um on the
second application for the agricultural
bangladesh master
i am the ward member um i will be
speaking on this but i'll be stepping
down
uh during the debate thank you very much
marvis thank you very much councillors
um that is it meeting chat so we shall
move on to our next item
which is the minutes can everyone give
me a thumbs up to say that they're happy
to confirm the minutes from the 3rd
of march that is a unanimous thumbs
up marvelous thank you very much i will
sign those when the next in the office
ok we'll move to our first planning
application which is the smithfield
sports club so i will hand over at this
point to councillor
fleming who will kill them for this item
okay thank you cheer um right agenda
item number seven
application number two zero oblique
stroke zero zero one three one
oblique stroke full um the uh
the first uh i'd like to invite planning
officer charlotte dix to present the
application please
thank you chairman let me just share my
screen with you
hopefully you're able to see that
yes we can thank you very much
okay so the site is indicated on the map
by the black circle
the application site is located at the
northern edge of snitterfield
at a higher ground level than the
village itself this slide shows the
relationship to the rest of the village
so this slide shows the application site
edged in red
the site is part of stitterfield sports
club and currently benefits from a
single story sports club building on the
northern part of the site
indicated by the yellow dot car parking
is to the side of the building
and outside the red line there are
tennis courts immediately to the east of
the site
and a bowling green to the south the
second parcel of land on the eastern
side
is currently open grassland
this is a full application for the
demolition of the existing sports club
building and the erection of a
replacement sports club building
and nine dwellings on the part of the
site closest to the wolverton road
the dwellings on the front would be set
back approximately four metres from the
highway
and there would also be five dwellings
fronting onto the proposed access road
running through the sites
located adjacent to the tennis courts
all parking for the nine dwellings would
be accessed directly off the access road
in these two
areas here the new sports club building
with its associated parking would be
on the eastern part of the site over
here
so this image shows the proposed
elevations of some of the dwellings and
these are the front elevations of plots
one to four which would front onto the
woolworths road
these dwellings are approximately 9.4
metres high
this image shows the proposed elevations
of plots five to nine which would front
onto the access road
and feature a parking bay directly to
the front
this slide shows the proposed elevations
of the replacement sports club building
when viewed from the tennis courts
so this photo shows the site on the left
hand side as you enter the village from
the north along the wolverton road
the site is where the low fencing is
here
with the access point just here the
existing oak tree mentioned within the
report
is visible here
this photo shows the front of the site
as viewed from wolverton road
the access is just off the screen to the
right hand side and the single story 3.6
meter high building can be seen with car
parking to the side
again the canopy of the oak tree is
visible and you can see the bowling
green on the right hand side of the
photo with the tennis courts and
associated flood lighting here
with distant views to the church beyond
so this photo is taken from the
wolverton road facing north
the site is on the right hand side here
where the car is visible
and then the properties on hail's place
are visible on the left hand side
showing that they're set back
approximately 10 meters from the lane to
the front
this photo is taken panning around to
show the front elevations of the
properties on hales close
and then this photo is taken from within
the site from the approximate position
of the front of the five plots which
would front the access road
again the tennis courts are visible on
the left hand side with the
bowling green on the right hand side the
access to the sports club would come
through this area here with the sports
club building
beyond the tennis courts in this sort of
approximate location
and this photo shows the location of the
proposed by sports club building
facing east towards the existing
boundary vegetation
so just to clarify there are updates
within the update sheet
and officer recommendation is to refuse
the application for planning permission
for the reasons and notes which are
found
on pages 20 and 21 of the agenda as well
as the additional reason for refusal
within the update sheet
thank you very much chairman
thank you
thank you for that charlotte i'm sorry
about the mutant thing um we've got
uh three speakers on this one and uh
first speaker we will be bringing in is
councillor claudian pearson
chairman of snitterfield paris council
and you're supporting the application
thank you
good evening members i represent fields
hello hello yes we can hear you all
right
can i start now yes start now yeah thank
you
good evening members i represent
snitchfield parish council
and its 1226 residents
many of whom belong to the smidfield
sports club the social club has 40
members
tennis 158 bowls 40
qriket 35 all-star kids 40
two table tennis teams sitterfield
homeschool group
snitterfield youth club all run by six
charity trustees
four volunteers a full-time steward
greenkeeper and bart staff
all of these residents use the club not
because of its condition
but despite it the application before
you is for a new sports facility
and nine two and three bed houses this
brownfield site was identified in our
neighborhood plan
made in 2018 with 94 percent of voters
saying yes
this application has taken two years to
determine and is now recommended for
refusal
the earth's officer's opinion is that
the application does not follow the
established form of development
with this mix of housing building
heights and pitches
our neighborhood plan committee
confirmed the layout and form of the
scheme before you
is entirely as was envisaged by the
committee when adopted as a key part of
the plan
delivering a new sports club facility
and smaller family homes for our
community
at the time the committee consulting
with the planning authority received
positive support for this exact layout
some members may recall the appleton
house site with eight
executive homes it is an example of
dominant and prominent additions in a
rural landscape
these are the officers words to describe
this application
not mine it can be seen from the club on
the brow of the hill opposite
it was not identified as a suitable site
in our ndp
members you can imagine how galling it
will be for our residents and the sports
club
to see this application refused on the
grounds of visual impact
and form turning to the officers other
reasons for refusal
smithfield parish council also
represents residents
impacted by flooding we have supported
this application
subject to the approval of the relevant
authorities
sid field is a well-established flood
group if members are minded
please grant permission and condition
this application subject to a drainage
strategy
satisfactory to the lead local flood
authority working with our flood group
finally smithfield tree action group are
working with the sports club to mitigate
the loss of the immature oak
by planting a woodland area hedges and
trees
in short members please be assured that
this is a development
led by the community for our community
sitterfield parish council
on behalf of the majority of residents
asks that you grant permission
for this application if necessary please
condition it
so that we may work with the authorities
avon homes and the sports club
to make it a development rule thank you
thank you very much uh councillor
pearson
and does anybody have any questions for
councillor pearson
doesn't appear so ah casa dixon
yes i i couldn't quite access my my chat
line unfortunately that pop-up but came
in the way
um uh council pearson um
i assume reading the officers report
my assumption is that there's been lots
of negotiations between uh
yourselves and the applicants as such
and uh sports club and the officers
yeah the site-specific allocations from
the ndp
indicate that in writing that
um there is a a reference that
the site should have roof pitches
which are reflective of the neighboring
developments
and of a shallow pitch and the building
heights should be lower
towards the edge of the building so as
to assist in the assimilation
of new developments into the surrounding
countryside
were negotiations etc regarding the roof
pitches
um made during those representations and
i just wondered what the views were as
to whether or not a shadow of a pitch
could have been achieved
i i and well this is the second uh
second layout uh of this application
um the houses have been adjusted in that
the ones to the front have been lowered
um i can only tell you that we have
looked at a number
of iterations and we are satisfied
that really for
our residents have to say
it is a detail that we find it more
important that the club
and the homes are built particularly
given that there are other developments
on the outskirts
uh coming into the billy road we have
the development of
affordable housing that does not fit in
with the built form of other houses
therefore
to us generally speaking it is a matter
of detail that we are prepared to accept
as a community
in order to have this development
that is the view of centerfield parish
council as an and
and the residents thank you very much
thank you right uh
following on we have another question
from council mills
thanks mr chairman um good evening um
you you have a a neighborhood plan you
say and
this featured in your neighborhood plan
has one have been adopted
yes it was adopted in 2018 and
fine that's all i need to know thank you
thank you
thank you counselor milt have we got any
other questions
for uh for councillor pearson
no nothing showing okay fine
thank you very much councillor pearson
you continue to listen on or you can
leave and listen on the live stream if
you want to do that
thank you very much for your input thank
you thanks bye-bye
okay right move on to the next speaker
is mr vincent ford
a local resident um councillor ford can
you hear us
was the point can we hear you
we did have councillor vincent in a
little while ago are you still there
councillor vincent
remember press star and six on your
phone to make to be heard
have you tried star and six
hello hello cancer
sorry mr ford yeah yeah yes can you hear
me
yes we can hear you now loud and clear
thank you great
well yes i'm not a dancer no i realize
that now
i'm an architect right okay um
with about 50 years experience well hang
on just one second
we'll start your time you've got six
minutes you'll be given a 30 second
warning when you're towards the end
of your six minutes okay carry on we've
got you we've got your statement thank
you
okay as i say i'm an architect and i've
had
over 50 years experience in housing and
sports buildings and i joined the
smithsfield
bowling club 14 years ago and started
the table tennis section two years
after that and i've attended many social
events and run fundraising activities
my objection is not so much about the
form of the architecture but more
the the layout everyone's in favor of
seeing
um nine new houses in a new clubhouse
uh including me but planning is about
ensuring good design not just providing
accommodation in designing this project
it would seem desirable to look for what
advantages the site offers
it's an elevated location fine southerly
views
over the village fields and the church
now none of the proposed gardens have
this aspect
they're all facing away into shade
it could be much better the scheme is
cramped
housing one meter from the flat
tennis courts at the east end and
too close to wolverton road for parking
at the west
there is encroaching um
100 square meters onto the bowls area to
the south
um the land taken from the bowl's
compound
is green belt outside the village
boundary
and this loss of land compromises the
bowls game
the housing site also incorporates a
dual use
through road to the clubhouse that is
not necessary
and a waste of space there is a much
shorter route from wolverson road
to the clubhouse south of the bowling
green
independent of the housing
highways prefer this separation of use
as it avoids
a conflict of safety
as children playing in a quiet
cul-de-sac
without fear of through traffic
conflict of noise from people leaving
the club in the late evening
and conflict of parking
in the the club members parking in the
housing slots
that are nearer to the tennis courts and
the
um bowls green than the clubhouse car
park
poor soil conditions two
civil engineers have confirmed
that this alternative road south of the
bowling green
would be feasible it would cost
about four forty thousand pound extra
for retaining walls etc
but this would be amply compensated
by at least 260
000 in the improved house prices
because you would have a a better layout
with
houses facing south and their cars
parked
directly outside their front door
instead of
being remote like this has been proposed
um by not having
a longer dual use through route
there would be more space better housing
layout
the tennis can have a wide landscape
margin
by the side of their court as they
wished
and the clubhouse can be positioned
adjacent to the bowling green as it
should be
at the moment there is a road going
between
the clubhouse and the bowling green very
unsatisfactory from a spectator's point
of view
the proposed spectator terrace to the
clubhouse
it's not overlooking the tennis or the
bowling green it's overlooking the car
park
this car park is about three foot
lower than the floor level of the
clubhouse
yet on the drawings there's no step
shown or
ramps for the disabled
there is no reception lobby to the main
entrance
it's just a meager corridor
route that is likely to be congested
with
access to the toilets the changing rooms
the store
and the kitchen on route
the men's changing room is too small
space for about 16 men there could be 48
at a bowl's match at any one time plus
people playing tennis there's no
stewards office
and there's no yard for refuse and
empties
there's a problem with overloading the
surface water drainage which has been
referred to
so we await decisions on that one
i believe the case office analysis for
the project is thorough and accurate
it would be progressive to believe
though that
we could cooperate towards an acceptable
better design in the future
that's all i have to say 30 seconds
thank you very much mr ford thank you
for that um does anyone have any
questions for mr ford
ah councilman mills has a question
thanks mr chairman uh good evening mr
ford um
mr ford um you're not objecting to
the um to a new clubhouse being built
or the houses it's just the design is it
not objecting to another um clubhouse
being built
it is the design you're concerned with
yes that's right okay that's what i need
to know thank you
okay any other questions for mr ford
just looking in the chat doesn't appear
to be anything else coming
okay then mr ford that looks like the
only question you're going to be
subjected to
so you can either carry on listening on
your phone or you can join the live
stream
um and thank you very much for your
input thank you
thank you okay
right then we'll move to uh speaker
three
uh and that's the agent sarah
butterfield um are you with us sarah
hi can you hear me yes we can you're
just about to say star sex on your phone
but
you've obviously got it i think it was
just a uh
a little time to kick in okay you've got
three minutes you'll get a warning for
when you've got 30 seconds left
and you've got three minutes and off you
go thank you
good evening chair and councillors the
proposed development before you
comprising nine dwellings and a new
clubhouse for smithy field sports club
fully accords with the requirements of
smittenfield neighborhood plan policy
ssa1
it is a point of viability that nine
dwellings are proposed the receipts from
the nine dwellings will allow the
replacement sports club to be provided
and a lower number of dwellings will not
allow the same
the two elements are intrinsically
linked without the residential
development on the existing clubhouse
site the new clubhouse facility will not
be delivered
jeopardizing the long-term future of the
club it is noted that officers raise no
objection to the proposed development in
principle
and the sports clubhouse is considered
acceptable moreover the proposed
materials and architectural features of
the dwellings are considered acceptable
and there will be no adverse impacts on
the immunity of neighbours or occupiers
ejection is raised to propose design of
the residential dwellings
where the scale and form is considered
excessive the applicant disagrees on
these points for the following reasons
in considering the village as a whole
there are examples of the use of
features such as dormer windows
parking that is not directly in front of
dwellings small front garden areas and
heights comparable to that proposed
such as at jago green cityfield lane and
shores close
the proposed parking spaces meet the
requirements of the council of spd
and warwickshire county council highways
raised no issue with the location of the
proposed parking spaces
the development providing dwellings
fronting wilberton road complies with
policy ssa one of the neighbourhood plan
which requires this design feature
the applicant acknowledges that there
are some outstanding points on technical
matters but additional submissions on
all of these have been submitted to the
planning department
firstly on highways and waste minor
changes have been made which fully
address the outstanding points including
visibility on the internal road network
the use of the turning head of the
sports club car park and showing that
two large cars can pass in opposite
directions
along the internal road further contrary
to comment in the officer report there's
no outstanding objection to visibility
onto warburton road to or from the site
axis
confirmed in the county hallways
response dated 15th october 2020.
secondly the proposed drainage scheme
for the site connects both foul and
surface water drainage to auburn road
the strategy makes the required
allowances for the proposed and
permeable area and also for climate
change
installing and utilising on-site water
storage to release water
in a controlled manner and at an agreed
rate as surface water runoff is
currently uncontrolled the proposed
system will result in a betterment
finally on trees the tree t2 identified
in the officer report is proposed for
removal to accommodate the nine
dwellings
it is acknowledged as being of a good
quality but it is also immature and not
subject to any protection
and the detailed landscaping plan for
the whole site can be conditioned as
part of any planning permission
the proposed application before the nine
dwellings and the delivery of a sports
clubhouse that will ensure the longevity
of the club
we request that in considering the
application members take into account
the matters referred to
as well as giving way to the benefits
the new sports clubhouse will deliver to
the local community
and also the significant local support
for the development and resolve to
support and approve the proposed
development
thank you
all right thank you sarah thank you for
that um i have a
any i'm going to say any questions for
sarah but councillor dixon's already got
one
registered so uh counselor dixon off you
go
thank you chairman good evening uh you
mentioned the
uh obviously it complies with that
specific site allocation on the in the
ndp
um i'll put the question to the parish
councillor
regarding the ridge heights um what i
could
ask if yourself given the experience and
your knowledge of the area
i would describe the these properties
potentially as two and a half story
um if that's an appropriate definition
are there any other two and a half story
properties
in the immediate vicinity on the other
side of the road on that estate
now i don't believe the onions are said
but there are within the village and and
on the edge of the village as well
and it's also sorry yeah no please carry
on
i was just going to say it's also i just
also would note that we
during the application we have them
worked with offices and the height of
the dwellings has been reduced by over a
meter from that originally submitted
yeah can that does the
uh do the the two and a half story ones
are they the three bedroom properties
uh yes thank you okay
thank you councillor dixon uh next on
the list uh
councillor jennings please okay thank
you chairman
so yeah you mentioned that you'd address
the technical matters
um on the flooding the highways waste
um just uh
and they don't they seem to come in very
late i mean i know that you've had
multiple conversations with highways etc
um but they seem to come in very late
and uh
i don't believe that any of those um
bodies have actually had a chance to
reply
no and we we um we received comments
from the llfa i think on the
15th or 16th of march so a technical
note has been prepared to respond to
those which we believe fully addresses
the matters
and similarly on highways that was also
submitted last week
undertaking some additional sweat path
analysis to
address the outstanding concerns um and
as i understand the lpa
and receipt of those so um the relevant
bodies
would still need to confirm that they
now fully address those points thank you
very much
okay thank you thank you cassidy uh
councillor parry you have a question
uh thank you chairman um it's really uh
councillor jennings almost has stolen my
thunder but my question is actually
along similar lines
because obviously you've got um a number
of items
um where you've updated
or you you've obviously had a drainage
strategy
submitted but we we're unaware of
what that is or or there hasn't been
sufficient time for the consult the
various
uh comments to be made and likewise with
the highways
i was just wondering um whether you'd
had any consideration to withdraw the
application until you'd had all this
information
in front of you in order that we could
consider
all the information and facts at
committee
um i think what we wanted to um to do
counselor
was get the um application in front of
you um
to discuss in essence the principle of
nine dwellings
um as you can imagine um
if officers were not happy with the nine
dwellings as proposed
um the other matters which also came in
in late in terms of responses the
drainage strategy was amended from that
originally submitted
um so we've had initial comments on that
amended drainage strategy and the final
matters for clarification
but um what we wanted to do was was seek
committee
support for for the nine dwellings as
proposed
um with an acknowledgement that a
decision may not be able to be formally
issued
until the final comments were received
from those relevant statutory bodies
thank you
sorry about that was muted um thank you
very much no other questions for sarah
now
am i allowed to ask the question it's
vincent ford here
no hello no no sorry mr ford now you
know
you've had your opportunity and we've
never had an opportunity to ask the
question
no you don't you no sorry you don't have
the opportunity to ask questions
we have the opportunity to ask questions
okay that's not in the procedure is it
only just that
you know sorry i'm sorry enough to stop
you because you could
you're going to come in with a question
on the sideways view there so
you've no no further opportunity to
speak thank you very much
okay right uh now there are no more
questions for
uh for sarah i think we'll move on to
ward member councillor richards
uh would you like to proceed i will
thank you councillor fleming
members i found myself in somewhat of a
quandary over this application if i'm
honest
um on the one hand i'm absolutely fully
supportive of the redevelopment of the
sports club
um and recognize the importance of
localism and the desire for snitfield
residents to have this site redeveloped
for nine houses and a sports club
pavilion as has been identified in their
ndp
but on the other hand we do still have
some outstanding outstanding concerns
expressed by both highways and
the llfa for those of you that know
snitfield sports club or have conducted
independent site visit you will know
that the club is in critical need of
renovation
quite frankly it needs knocking down and
replacing as a matter of urgency it's
not safe
that has been known for some time and in
2014-15 when the village
embarks on its ndp there was much
discussion about this site
ultimately the ndp committee concluded
that this site should be redeveloped for
nine homes
with a new sports club under policy ssa
one and as you've heard from the parish
council that ndp
was supported by 94 of residents at
referendum stage
that for me shows overwhelming local
support
indeed having spoken to a number of the
ndp committee members
this week i am told that the current
proposal is more or less exactly
how they have envisaged the development
when it was first included in the ndp
regrettably we are now in front of you
with a recommendation to refuse
where the case officer has in the report
and a sixth in the update sheet reasons
for
uh that recommendation taking the first
reason of scale
uh design layout and citing in my mind
that is very much subjective
and each of us can have a differing view
on such matters in these circumstances i
believe it is right for us to give
significant weight to the opinions of
the local residents
that this development directly impacts
we know that 94
of the village supported this
development through the ndp process
and during the application alone there
have been 70 letters of support with
just 11 objections
for me that gives us a good steer as to
how the residents see this development
fitting in with the village
and that alone satisfies me that the
development would be appropriate in
terms of design scale and layout and
sighting
however i do have a good understanding
of the village and the location of the
sports club in relation to other areas
of the village
properties along wolverton road and
dutton's close and hills closed which
are directly opposite
are tightly packed and do closely above
the road similar to
the design and layout that is being
proposed to my mind this development
does fit in and with and relates to the
character of the surrounding area
and it does preserve the special
landscape area particularly when
compared to surrounding forms of
development
members i didn't request a site visit in
the lead up to this meeting purely
because we are still in lockdown and
government guidance is to stay at home
however if you're unconvinced about the
design
layout sighting scale then i would
suggest that
you consider deferring to enable you to
conduct a site visit
after the 12th of april when our
restrictions have been lifted
notwithstanding that we'd still be left
with four other reasons for refusal
specifically insufficient information
about visibility displays and parking
layout
insufficient information that to
demonstrate refuse vehicles can
adequately serve
service to site insufficient information
about drainage
and information relating to the loss of
a mature oak tree
we do have another one i'm afraid i
haven't uh got that in my my
text in my opinion each of these issues
can
be easily overcome simply by obtaining
the required information
and to that end i along with each of you
have received a report last friday from
the applicant
where they provide further detail in
relation to each of these areas of
concern
and clearly demonstrate that these
reasons for refusal can be and in most
cases have been
overcome so in my mind
there are a couple of options available
to you at this stage
the first one provided you're satisfied
with the design
layout scale and sighting and it does
fit into the character of the area
and the applicant's report that you've
been provided does overcome the concerns
identified
by highways in the llfa then you can
grant subject conditions
however if you're not satisfied by
either
one or both of the design layout scale
and citing
or the applicant's report overcoming uh
the outstanding areas of concern
then to my mind you should defer to
enable a committee to either conduct a
site visit to see the location see its
location in the surrounding area
and or to allow the applicant to
continue to provide the necessary
information
to address the outstanding concerns you
will have seen
in the update sheet the additional
information has been noted
um and a specific comment does say uh
that it has
it has not been possible to send these
details out for consultations again the
views of the relevant
consultees i think we have a duty to
ensure that that does go
and we do get responses from them so to
my mind a deferment at this stage would
be the right thing to do
we do have overwhelming support from the
residents from the parish council
the neighborhood development planning
team and myself
and as i say i think it would be right
now to defer so that this information
can be assessed
by the right people but i will leave it
to your judgment thank you very much
okay thank you councillor richards does
anybody have any questions for the ward
member
oh i think we do counselor dixon has a
question
thank you chairman uh councillor
richards uh
the ndp um and
the housing assessment as such
um i lost started to look at this one a
bit more closely because i was
anticipating exception sites and the
like
for housing within the green belt
because obviously this is a green belt
site
and uh the idea of total market housing
made me uh look a little bit further and
i also
see on page nine of our report the 71
letters of support
where one of the comments there
admittedly uh
combined by the by the by the planners
much needed housing to the appropriate
size in accordance with the ndp
now we're talking about three-bedroom
properties here
at market housing and i just wondered if
in your recollection uh whether the need
in the community
is for houses for local people
because essentially i'm wondering
and fearing that nine market houses
might be unavailable by price
for local people and whether or not the
ndp was really for local people
just wondered if you had a view on that
um i i do have a view on that um
i don't have uh in front of me details
of
our housing needs assessment um what i
would say is that um
we could be one could be seen to be
muddy in the water by introducing that
now clearly the ndp
does identify nine houses it doesn't say
local market houses it doesn't say
anything else uh about those types of
houses
just as nine houses on that site and
that is what's been presented in front
of us now
um and again within you you mentioned
greenbelt within the report you'll have
seen that the case officer has detailed
uh greenbelt issues and
has concluded that it is an appropriate
form of development in the green belt
thank you peter thank you guys addiction
uh councillor mills has a question
thanks mr chairman i'm
just a curiosity peter did visit the
site
although during covered restrictions it
was considered work
so i was able to go along um peter is
is the clubhouse closed at the moment
because
it is partly because it has to be
yeah and it is also unsafe i mean
it's it looks like the club wouldn't
would
open it if we were able to if the club
were able to
to allow members to be able to continue
to use the sports facilities
but it really is in a dire state and in
desperate need of renovation and repairs
frankly as i say it needs knocking down
and rebuilding okay
thank you and cancer riches have got a
question
not a question more of an a statement in
reality really
um i used i shot there regularly with
the
the sorry the strategy
um and two or three years ago it could
have done with it
could have done with a lot of work at
that stage um so we
actually haven't shot for 18 months
there but the whole point about it is
that
uh it was it was a building that was in
some serious need of
either restoration or you know first
the first thing to buy to improve the
thing would be a jcb and knock it down
um so so from that perspective
i can support why people want a new a
new build in there
um but you know i'm just a little bit
concerned about the housings but anyway
thank you very much for that
thank you
right so now um we'll move on to
uh point of clarification for questions
from the
uh the members to the officers please
oh we've got we've got a queue um right
we'll go for uh
cancer jennings first he was first
i think i was
it's just just the way it came up on my
screen
oh i'll jump the gun then um yes a quick
one that um
if we were mindful to grant this could
we have um
could we put the conditions
um that obviously i've got
i've got issues with the flooding the
highways the waste that
could we could we grant subject to
those conditions being satisfied
although
or would we be better off just deferring
in offices view it would be better to
allow the additional information that
we've received recently to be
considered and for the consultees to
have chance to respond
and to to ensure that the the the
objections that they raise
can be overcome um in terms of all the
issues
you've mentioned in terms of the
drainage and the highways and the refuse
tracking as well
the best way of doing that is i would
presume would be by default
yes if members were inclined to to
accept the information to be considered
yes
it would be best to recommend deferral
in this case great
that's all i needed to know okay uh
councillor parry as i
uh went out of order you go next please
well of course councillor jennings has
stolen my thunder because i was going to
um suggest that if we were minded to
defer
could that could it be deferred so that
we were able to see
all the outstanding information prior to
it coming back to committee again
okay thank you for that guys to parry uh
who actually got cancer dixon thank you
chairman
uh charlotte um were discussions uh
had with the applicants regarding not
only the ridge height but possibly
the number of bedrooms because
essentially
it's my assumption correct me if i'm
wrong that the
two and a half story houses are purely
intended to be able to
provide the third bedroom and if they
were in
fact two-bedroom properties the ridge
height would become lower
and indeed they would be closer to the
housing assessment that is in part of
the ndp
yes um i did discuss with the agent
regularly in terms of the uh
the proposal in terms of reducing the
reg height and
as she had mentioned there were amended
plans submitted as part of the
live application which did reduce the
ridge height
um but just um not enough for us to be
satisfied that the
that the the building heights would be
commensurate with the surrounding
development
and you are right in saying um as i
understand it that the
the height is required um to provide the
uh
the rooms within the reef which which
would be the additional bedrooms
so yes if the if the heights were
reduced it would reduce the ability to
actually provide the headroom in the uh
in in the loft space for those bedrooms
are the two are there two rooms in the
loft space two bedrooms in the space or
just the one charlotte
it's just one bedroom proposed in each
of the properties in in the reef space
right so they'd be they would become
two-bedroom properties instead of
three-bedroom
that's correct thank you okay
thank you cancer dixon right any further
questions for officers
no nothing nothing in the chat okay well
thank you very much for that charlotte
thank you
um right we'll move on to uh to members
debate
anybody want to kick that one off oh
cancer party definitely was first that
time
so uh counselor parry you go first um
well i think all of us are very keen
that we should
um and recognize that snitchfield needs
a new sports club
um for me unfortunately the committee
report in front of me there are just
too many gaps um
to to support the to support with a
grant
subject to the conditions so my proposal
is to defer
uh until all the sufficient information
has come forward then we can make an
appropriate decision
once all the information has been
gathered thank you
okay thank you so that's the proposal
already have a segment
um next one in was counselor edin
are you muted again
we can't see your lips move but that's
it
i think he wanted to make a mute point
okay
thank you for that i wondered how long
it would take
you should be able to hear me now sorry
firstly i think jennings next but um
anyway uh
along the lines of um councillor parry
uh i i think there's not quite enough
here for us to grant now um and i don't
think we should be taking away the
opportunity for the good people of
centerfield to
get their redevelopment done i don't
have many problems much beyond what
seemingly can be satisfied with some a
bit more time so i think we should defer
as well but i'll let
councillor jennings do the second thing
okay radio um
councillor crump was next to the he said
he's happy to second
i think we've got several people wanting
to second that including councillor
jennings
um councillor jones i think was first
with the second thing so
would you like to go ahead with that yes
i would i'd just like to add that i
don't have a problem with the layout
type of houses visual impact i don't
have a problem with any of these things
um the fact that this is that some of
them got three bedrooms i'm presuming
that if you then
chop them down and make make them lower
that
it won't make financial sense and
probably the whole thing will collapse
um i think the the only issues which
are outstanding let's say you know the
flooding highways
the lf llfa um obviously we have to i
want those to be coming
and to be considered um
the the tree issue i've got a problem
with that they've already suggested a
way of uh
replanting so um so my only issue is
i think we just need a bit of time to go
through
to make sure that they're satisfied all
the points
um and so i'm happy to second they're
deferring
okay uh councillor crump do you still
want to make a point or are you
just very briefly i know a short time
tonight yeah i
fully understand the value of sporting
organizations in the community and
and how it's good for mental health and
benefits and
team building etc so i'm supportive but
i think we've got to get it right
and i think we need the information so
that's the reason why
i'm either second in or third in uh
councillor parry's
proposal okay um thank you thank you
very much okay
councillor dixon you want to make it you
you're requesting a site visit correct
uh essentially yes chairman um i do have
concerns regarding
you know it's we have had reference to i
think the parish councillors and the
others
that there are other examples locally
but to my mind
two uh two bad apples don't make a good
one um so essentially
our job is to protect and enhance the
environment
and i am fearful that these are going to
be on the edge of the village
9.4 meters at ridge height just too high
to to dominance etc so i do have
fears there but a site visit might
alleviate those
i do not know okay thank you very much
to that point
um tracy you want to come in to make a
point
thank you chairman yes i've been
listening to the the debate as members
have expressed it
it would be helpful for officers to
understand
on what basis members are deferring it
we need to be clear if
some of you are accepting of the the
layout and scale of development
or if indeed you're asking for the
application to be deferred for all
issues to be provided with further
information
submissions and potentially including a
site visit so it will clearly be helpful
to officers to understand that
and secondly can i just point out on the
update sheet
um that the um the housing and enabling
officer pointed out that there is a
contribution
for affordable housing that would be
required um
that would need to be the subject of a
section 106
agreement or alternatively if viability
uh
remains the case with the scheme then we
would offer the applicant the
opportunity to explore
through further viability assessments
whether there was a case to waive our
affordable housing policies or not
but that piece of work would need to be
done in parallel with the consultation
with
the county highways and the llfa and so
forth on those outstanding technical
matters
so in fairness there is a broad range of
additional work
uh which we feel is needed in order for
uh for
for members to to form a uh a solid
conclusion on the application okay uh
just before i
bring councillor mills in uh case of
parry wants to make a point i think
well having proposed it um i mean part
of the reason for deferring it i just
feel it's a bit premature because we
haven't got
in particular the information regarding
the drainage
and the highways which are totally
essential
plus we have the other areas of concern
um where it hasn't been confirmed the
waste and recycling of the bins
plus also um you know
the the contribution as far as the
affordable housing
the reason for deferring is is there in
my view
i felt there were too many outstanding
issues where information wasn't
forthcoming
um and a deferral therefore was was a
much better option
than refusing it outright okay thank you
casey mills yes thanks mr chairman yeah
um
yes i think we looks like we're going
for a determiner but uh i mean
we are it looks like they're in need of
this um
at this new clubhouse uh everything
looks a mess at the moment
um uh am i allowed to say which way i
would go at the moment
um but um i i'm quite happy with it all
at the moment to be honest mr chairman
but um
i'll go with the other members that they
want to go deferment and on a site visit
something okay uh peter henderson would
like to make a
comment thank you chair um
i think the application is fine uh i
have concerns of the
layout of the houses would be my concern
and the road going past them uh i agree
with mr ford that
if the access road was south of the uh
bowling
green it would be uh more
useful to the family homes and children
could play
safer but you know i'm more for
deferring it
and getting things right yes okay okay
thank you right so uh so from that
perspective
it's uh there's no further questions and
uh i think from that perspective we can
we can move to the vote and and see
where we have we've got a proposal
and we've got seconders and uh
i think we'll we'll move to the vote and
and the proposal we've got is that we
defer until we're fully aware of all the
other uh questions being answered
and that uh we're full in in full view
of all the
information we have um
councillor dixon's asking about site
visits um
chair do i need to propose a site visit
and see if that is seconded by anybody
because i would like to see the
committee attend
not just informal visits by ourselves
independently
i much prefer site visits with the
planning officer there
i understand that yes you can certainly
propose that we have
we had a site visit to the yet to the
conditions yes
so ca councillor parry do you accept
that we should
uh propose a site visit to go along with
your proposal yeah i mean i'm quite
happy to have a site visit
um normally site visits uh it it's just
very difficult for for everybody to
attend because
most of us are have a day job
um i'm very familiar with the site
because i know sitterfield and i'm the
county councillor for the site
but um certainly i think if the officers
were to make
themselves available to those who wanted
to go on a site visit
then that's not a problem to me okay
thank you
i would welcome that okay so the
proposal we've got is to defer
have a site visit and wait till we're
fully armed with all the information we
need
to make a decision so we've got a
proposal and we have a second
so we go to the vote then please check
can i just confirm that councillor
crump's okay with seconding
that still yes certainly
i think it wasn't it counts the on
either
i thought it was cancer jennings of
second i think i came in third
it was it was cancer generally yeah and
i'm happy with that
brilliant okay we'll go to the vote then
say um
councillor fleming for
councillor crump clowns the comp for
councillor dixon
and councillor mills council meals for
and councillor parry
councillor parry four unanimous chair
sorry i missed uh dropped out for a
second
unanimous chair okay thank you very much
so the the decision is then
that we yeah we go for a deferral with a
site visit
and come back at a later date thank you
very much
okay so now i have to hand back to
councillor richards to to move on to the
next item on the agenda
brilliant thank you very much councillor
fleming um thank you members okay our
next item then is application reference
twenty zero
three three nine five ful that is the
agricultural building court fields
bridge road in butler's marston our
present composer is louise casey
louise are you there yeah yeah
marvelous whenever you're ready over to
you thank you chairman
i'll just share my screen bear with me
today thank you very much
sorry louise before you start let me um
i think we've got some of our speakers
are in
um we're just going to mute our speakers
because we're getting some feedback and
just to remind uh speakers that have
just joined us when you do
come to speak if you could please either
turn off or mute
any of the um live streams in the
background they are slightly delayed
and they do give us feedback when you're
speaking over the phone so if you could
follow on from your phone
uh that would be preferable at this
stage sorry louise over to you
no worries so the application now before
members seeks planning permission for
the demolition
of two agricultural barns and the
erection of three new dwellings with a
detached garage
the application site is situated within
the village of butler's marston which is
categorized as an order settlement
location
it's denoted by the black dot on this
plan
so the site is outlined here in red
other than the open countryside location
there are no particular site constraints
and as it stands there are two extant
approvals on site to convert the
existing
large agricultural building to
residential use under class queue of the
general permitted development order
so here we can see an aerial view of the
site so it just shows the site in
context of the surrounding pattern of
development
and moving on to the plans so
in this slide here on the left we've got
the existing site layout and on the
right is the proposed site they are
and here we've got proposed plan
servations for unit one which is the
largest of the three dwellings uh this
one's proposed to have four bedrooms um
one and a half stories in height
and then here you've got unit two um
both plans and elevations this one a
three bedroom dwelling
one and a half stories in high again and
then finally unit three which is single
story
and also a three bedroom dwelling
oh just bear with me a second my notes
have just closed on me
no problem
apologies about that so um in this slide
we can see the approved plans for the
first of the two extant approvals on
site
um and i think it should be born in mind
here that development
under class q must be completed within
three years of the date
of the approval which in this case would
be the 17th of august this year so
that's in less than five months time
the developers not yet submitted an
application to discharge any conditions
um two of which are pre-commencement
conditions so works hasn't begun on site
just yet
this approval allows for the conversion
of the larger agricultural building
into three residential units each unit
would comprise two bedrooms
and the residential curtis of the
dwellings would be restricted to within
the red line you can see
on the side plunges
the external finish of the building as
well is yet to be determined as
condition two of the approval requests
material samples to be submitted to the
authority for consideration
so this next slide shows the approved
plans for the second of the two extent
approvals on site
um the approval allows for the
conversion again of the larger
agricultural building
into a single four-bedroom unit
the external finish again is yet to be
determined there's however more times
carryout works committed under this
approval which must be completed by the
6th of may 2023
so now turning to some images of the
application
site here we've got the large
agricultural building
in the foreground with the dutch barn
the second agricultural building just
beyond
and this photo was taken from bridge
road to the front of the site
and then finally we've got some photos
here from within the surrounded street
scene
again each of these photos taken from
bridge road at the front
of the site so
to conclude the application site is in a
location where new housing can only be
supported where it's proposed as a
community-led scheme
as the application proposes open market
housing there is a conflict with the
development plan
a key material planning consideration in
this instance is the existence of
two extent approvals on site to convert
the larger of the two agricultural
buildings to residential use
the proposed development however has
been found to result in tangible harm
over and above that caused by either of
the classical approvals
this harvest in terms of both principle
of development and the impact on the
character
of the locality and the wider landscape
chairman it is therefore recommended
that planning permission is refused for
the reason set out within the report and
there are no
updates marvelous louise thank you very
much for that
and we will move straight to our first
speaker who is counselor jenny mitchell
hilton from butler's martin parish
council
uh councillor are you there can you hear
me you may need to press star and six to
unmute your
keypad
counselor mitchell ah we can hear you
good evening
hello um so yes i speak this easily on
behalf of martin parish council in
support of the planning
there's been unanimous support from all
councillors and as our chair has
declared interest in this planning she's
obviously been limited to many
discussions regarding the planning
there is um do you have my slides
available
i will check with our officers do we
have any slides available can we bring
them up if we do
apologies i will just get them now
of them are repeats from from the
planning officer so i was will through
with will with through them quickly as i
speak counsellor sorry i'm just going to
pause you just for a moment while we
bring those up
um when we will start the clock in just
a moment you'll have three minutes and
we'll give you a 30 second warning
obviously if you can stay online
afterwards that would be helpful
um i'm struggling to hear you a little
bit the line sounds a bit muffled i
don't know whether
there's something over a microphone or
quite what um
is that better that is much better yes
thank you okay great
always i'll let you know when we've got
the slides in front of us
yeah just going to share my screen now
okay we have the slides in front of us
now counselor so whenever you're already
please do start
okay so as i've previously mentioned
there has been a consensus of opinion
from all those i've spoken to within the
village
and from the 17 comments that have been
in support of the um planning on the
e-planning
system if you can move to slide two
the parish council feels that the scheme
would be far more in keeping with the
surroundings and the aesthetics of the
village
than the proposed class q planning
as you can see the existing structures
are currently disassociated
um and there's three reasons that we
feel that the exist the proposed
planning would
be better than the um class q the
reduction in bulk the materials used and
the
contribution to the community spirit and
the overall
feeling of the village slide three
um as the barn is in such close promises
proximity to the road it's imposing as
you enter and exit the village its
presence is further exacerbated by its
current state
and would further be further so we feel
by the use of modern and incongruous
materials
such as those in the current planning
the significant reduction in bulk
calculated to be 728 meters cubed
and the more dispersed layout we feel
would mean the development be
significantly less imposing
and far more consistent with the size of
surrounding housing
you can move to slide four five and six
which i know the flying officer has
already said
i'm onto slide seven the neighboring
houses you can see here sit very close
to the road
and are much smaller buildings than the
ones that you can already see
exist with the barns currently many of
the local houses
if you can see on slide eight if we skip
on are
dating back to the 1800s and we feel
that the materials
um would be much more um
closely linked to the ones that exist in
the village
on slide nine the proposed plans outline
materials including white lion stone
which is far more on keeping with the
adjacent houses
as you can see on slides 10 11 and 12.
one of which is the view from the
development the wall that you can see
the houses that continue along bridge
road
and the neighboring property which is on
top slide 12.
the proposed materials in this
application would be much more
sympathetic to the local area
the existing queue plans include
significant amounts of glass and
clubbing because there are no similar
villages
there's no similar buildings in our
village and we feel that such a large
amounts of glass and cladding would be
in huge contrast to and would look much
more industrial than any other building
that sticks along this road
please skip on slide 14.
these other modern looking barns that
exist 30 seconds
and we feel this would be as i say in
contrast to the buildings demonstrated
finally wanted to say that but martin is
a small village with a strong community
spirit and we feel that the layout of
these houses in such a
small group in a community feel would
encourage people who would opt in to and
further grow our community
i hope you've been able to consider this
application for the merits it would
bring to our village and the positive
impact we feel it would have on our
neighboring houses and the wider village
scene
thank you marvelous thank you very much
let me see if we have any questions for
you councillor members do we have any
questions please indicate the chat
if you do our first question is from
councillor parry councillor parry
thank you chair um and good evening
um councillor i just wanted to ask
um has butler's marston parish council
carried out a housing needs survey
tool in the last few years
there has been a um housing news survey
carried out i think
probably about five six years ago and
the need was for
small to two to three bedroom houses
that were affordable to local residents
and personally i think the village the
parish council feels that they
put this planning would be much more
accessible to those residents
um than a larger sort of barn conversion
thank you okay thank you members
i'm not seeing anything else in the chat
if anyone else has a question please
indicate now otherwise we will move on
i will give you a couple of seconds
looks like that's going to be a no so
councillor thank you very much for your
contribution this evening you're
probably best placed to continue to
watch the live stream
on your uh on another device but thank
you very much okay thank you
okay we will move to our next speaker
who is mr dan jackson the agent mr
jackson are you there can you hear me
you may need to proceed marvelous i can
hear you now as well so you have three
minutes
we'll give you a 30-second warning
whenever you're ready do feel free to
start
thank you very much good evening members
um
you have a fantastic opportunity this
evening to make a positive contribution
to this corner of butler's marston
and put localism into action we have
before it's an application which seeks
to replace a large
overbearing utilitarian barn conversion
with a small collection of stone
dwellings set within a courtyard
you've seen as part of the presentation
visuals of the existing consent against
what is proposed
and we have here a prominent site on the
gateway to the village
and a real opportunity to make a
positive change
i know from experience how class-key
barn conversions can divide opinion at
the best of times
and whatever is determined tonight will
make a lasting impact on the village of
butler's marston
love it or hate it the class permission
is in place and could at any time be
implemented
in accordance with the already approved
plans
my clients have lived in the village for
generations and their preferences for us
much smaller
more sympathetic development this new
scheme represents a volume reduction of
32 percent less than what is already
approved
and has been designed to replicate a
traditional courtyard of barn
conversions
using local stone slate and appropriate
soft landscaping
this reduction in matting and use of
sensitive materials is in my view far
less harmful and more fitting to the
area
now i'm preparing this evening i note
the next item on the agenda for
consideration is very similar in nature
and in that incident the officer is
recommending approval and i think
summarizes the position very well in her
committee report by saying on balance
i conclude that the proposal is a
betterment by comparison to the
previously approved class queues
i therefore consider that the class
queue to be a legitimate fallback
which weighs in favor of the
application's approval
in this case we have consulted very
heavily with local residents and been
overwhelmed by the support from the
people
who wish to see this more appropriate
development in their village
the ward member and parish council have
been kind enough to offer their own
compelling letters and words of support
this evening
as to why they endorse the proposals and
it's not often we see housing
applications come before committee with
no objections at all
in appraising this application this
evening we can put localism into action
and send a positive message to the
village that we are listening to their
views
common sense in the planning system
don't always go hand in hand but we've
got an opportunity to make a positive
commitment to good town planning and
place making
thank you very much mr jackson thank you
very much
um please hold on the line and i'll see
if we have any questions for you
we do uh councillor dixon is first
councillor dixon
thank you chairman uh mr jackson uh the
uh i think it's a dutch barn that uh
currently doesn't have
or hasn't any involvement with the
classic q at the present time
is it a redundant agricultural barn or
has it been used recently for
agriculture i wouldn't want to see a
replacement being constructed
down a field as it were can you advise
uh it is redundant yes i can advise it
it's redundant
and would be replaced in granting this
scheme this evening
sorry it would not need to be replaced
it's no longer no longer there's no
longer a requirement for
agricultural buildings here there's no
need thank you
lovely thank you okay members i'll give
you a couple more seconds if you want to
stick a question into
the chat otherwise we will move on
i'm not seeing much movement from our
members so i'm going to assume that we
have no further questions so uh mr
jackson thank you very much for your
contribution
again you're probably best placed to
continue to watch the live stream on
another device and can help you thank
you thank you very much
okay will move to our final speaker for
this item which is councillor mills
council mills you've gone from my screen
are you there
i am marvellous i'm still here can you
see me
i can now um so you have five minutes at
30 second warning you know the drill
over to you thank you good evening
committee
um these dilapidated barns
are and have been an eyesore for some
time and the fact they will be replaced
by three new splendid looking dwellings
has delighted the residents of butler's
marston
as you can see uh in this photograph
here
they are pretty darn awful um
there's been one objection from cpre but
no objections from stratfor district
council environmental health
no objections from warwickshire county
council
warwick county council highways no
objection from warwickshire county
council
ecology no objection from warwickshire
county council fire and rescue and no
objection from
master and parish council but there have
been 17 letters of support from
residents of butler's marston
the report says that the new dwellings
will be of a similar footprint and be of
similar height
in fact they will be lower also the
dutch barn which has been
used to be converted into garages will
be also lower in height
the garden areas of the proposed
dwellings will be much larger than the
approved under the prior approval
application well committee how good is
that because we often see with new
builds yet the gardens are almost
minuscule
as been stated before the materials
being used will be white lie stone
will blend in and match with the
surrounding area and the design of the
proposed dwellings
is very sympathetic and will merge with
neighboring properties
the report also says it will cause harm
to the character and the appearance of
the locality but in my opinion
the proposed weddings will enhance the
outlook of
the committee of the locality um i just
wanted to bring up the photograph of the
approved application as it is at the
moment not my car that's
it thank you as you can see by this
photo the plans and design of the new
dwellings are far superior
to the previously granted application
this new application will enhance the
locality
and in my mind in my opinion does not
detract or cause harm
as laid out in the report and in my mind
more pleasing to the eye
the report also says the layout is
considered to be generally acceptable in
regard to residential amenity
the plot would provide an adequate
standard of outdoor space
in terms of both size and for the future
occupies of the properties
the report also can you continue to say
the proposal is at sufficient
neighboring distance
in regard not to cause any harmful
impacts in terms of overbearing
overshadowing and overlooking impacts i
just want if we could get up the um
the plans showing the the new proposal i
know it's just to remind um
[Music]
committee please could you put it up
there please louise
although we yeah let me just get hold of
it
with me okay
so that your time doesn't round can't
run out cancel mills you want to carry
on with what you're saying
um although the report says it will be
departure from the previous application
committee please look at this
application as a vast improvement
and i'll put it to the members of the
committee that if you had the choice of
choosing
between the two applications in buying a
new home
which design would you prefer therefore
i asked the committee to grant this
application
many thanks marvelous council mills
thank you very much for that members
could you indicate in the chat if you
have any questions for councillor mills
please
i'll give you a few seconds to do that
uh council dixon first please
i thought it would be tony thank you
chairman uh councillor mills uh
certainly the the look of what is there
currently
um i'm sure that many of us can see
similar sites
all across the whole of south to
warwickshire
and these are mostly in areas which are
not available for redevelopment and new
housing
which is where of course the policy does
tend to strike against
this proposal before us um
if you had the opportunity to change
policy
would you basically say all of these
barns across south warwickshire which
are no longer required but our eyesores
should be replaced that's
uh subjective uh would i say they all
need to be placed
if they replace no if there was a decent
design
fine but this is not a decent design
uh the original application these are
far superior
and in that case this one does need to
replace depends on where it is
okay thank you very much councilman uh
councillor crump
as well on your towers councilman just
very briefly
um i think my internet was a bit
unstable
i got the impression that you there was
strong significant local support on this
and you mentioned
just very briefly mention that because
you just don't take it for a minute
yes um uh councillor trump yes there's
been
uh 17 letters of support uh from
residents of butler's marston
as well as the parish council um yes
i say everybody's delighted that uh to
see these new that
hopefully the new buildings go up thank
you
thank you very much sorry sorry about
that no thank you both um
does anyone else have any questions for
councillor mills at this point i'll give
you a couple of seconds to indicate in
the chat i'm seeing some shaking heads
you know i'm going to assume that's not
to cancel mills thank you very much
thank you thank you let's move on
to points of clarification for our
officers members do we have any points
for clarification please indicate the
chat
if you do i will give you a couple of
seconds
i'll take that as a no in that case
let's move to debate who would like to
kick us off
please indicate in the chat if you would
like to
or i will pick on someone counselor
jennings was in
first just cancer jennings thank you
very much chairman
um i love barn conversions
if i had a choice between the three
houses
or that one big massive barn conversion
i'd go for the big barn conversion
every single time but that's just fine
that's just my own uh preference but
um on this one class q
is for converting bonds into residential
and there are lots of stipulations and
hurdles which you have to jump through
in order to do that it's not a green
light to start
building multiple new houses instead of
one barn
um if it was a one for one
then you know i'm probably be more
sympathetic
to it but at the moment i'm kind of
struggling
that yes you have x amount of space you
then just say well
i'll chop that up into ten small little
houses because the mass will be smaller
than one big barn
that's not the way the class q is
supposed to work
in my opinion so
i'll i'll throw it out to her whatever's
next
marvelous thank you very much cancer
jennings counselor parry next please
thank you chairman well as someone who
works in kington um
i actually visit butler's marston quite
frequently
so i am very familiar with the village
architecture and its setting
and i have to say that this new proposal
in front of us is way more in keeping
than the um the
extent of permission that we have that
that is on the site
um and particularly um i am familiar
with this particular
site and it and it does almost provide a
sort of a gateway entrance
into the village um it's very rare that
we get
parish council support and ward member
support
and 17 letters of support from
local villagers there aren't that many
dwellings in butler's marston so i i
i know full well that actually to get 17
people supporting an application is
quite a large number a percentage-wise
of villagers i think we've had some very
good presentations from both the parish
council
and the ward member and i think it is a
case
that actually what we have in front of
us is far more aesthetically appealing
i do think it enhances the character of
the village
so i'm going to go against the officer's
recommendation
and go for grant on the basis that i
feel that it is more in keeping
with the village and i don't i think
there is less harm caused by this
particular development and i think a lot
of thought has gone
gone into it yes if they built the
previous one
they probably financially would make far
more money on it
but i think what we have in front of us
is
certainly something that will sit very
well
in the village and be complementary
so in my view its common sense prevails
so i will go in support of this
application thank you
thank you very much councillor parry
councillor dixon next please
thank you chairman i'm on councillor
jennings
uh side if this argument in truth uh
policy does not support the replacement
of one
barn with three
detached properties essentially
the conversion of one bar into one bar
or even one big barn
into three smaller units but comprised
within that one advanced structure
now we hear from the planning officers
that they don't think
the conversion of it into three
properties will be viable
because of the time constraints there's
still that permission therefore
for the developer owner to follow
councillor paris suggestion that the one
bond would probably be more financially
viable
i would suggest in truth the only reason
we've got this application before us
tonight
is because the owner developer thinks
there's more money to be made
from three properties instead of the one
conversion
unfortunately three properties is not
within policy
and i must be against this and it's
supporting the officer's recommendation
thank you very much council dixon i just
stress at this point um clearly
uh how much money one might make from a
development is not a planning
concern um i understand why you're
making the points but it's not a
planning concern so
members please bear that in mind and
counseling seraphim next please
thank you chair yes i think the previous
application of the barn looks quite ugly
and doesn't uh match anything else in
the village
now these um stone-built dwellings
they would improve the area totally
and to me it's a no-brainer this
i would totally support this application
simple as that
thank you thank you very much councillor
um and
anyone else would like to speak at this
point before i put my two pennies worth
in cancer crump
please again just very briefly yeah i
support
council parry's view on this um we don't
always follow
follow a policy and uh i believe in
the local members local views and local
support of
of applications if the community wants
it
they are going to be the people that be
living there okay you could argue that
they won't be living there in 50 or 100
years time
but i certainly see the merits in this
application and
would be uh supporting uh happy to
second
if councillor parry proposed
propose the application not proposed
marriage of course sorry casey perry
let's uh let's keep the focus on
planning shall we for the evening um
okay thank you very much councillor
crump i can't see anyone else indicating
the chat their desire to speak so i will
put my two pennies worth in before we
move on
to a vote um council jennings made the
point that class q
is there for uh for a reason um and
there are very tight guidelines that one
must
abide or stick to when they're when
getting a class q
i believe that includes maintaining the
outer fabric and general shape of
whatever the building might be
um my concern here is that we've
approved something under class q
on the basis that it maintains that
shape and would maintain the
uh the the views uh around that area
and now we're looking to completely go
against that remove it and put houses on
so i do have a little bit of a problem
with that um
that being said i do also agree with the
comments made by other members that
the proposal is significantly better in
terms of its
uh appearance that it and this is again
it's a subjective it's my personal view
but i think it's significantly better
in terms of its appearance than the the
currently proposed and granted barnes
um given we've been told that the
size of the volume size i believe it was
is 32 less than is currently approved
i think that is quite a strong case to
say
that the impact it's going to have is 32
less and therefore we could move towards
a grant
the way i'm trying to look at it is if
that had been built out would i be happy
for those buildings to be knocked down
and built out in the way that they are
and i think
purely on this site and it is site
specific
i think i probably would be inclined to
do that so i'm supportive um and i think
cancer para did propose i was gonna
second but that's been done by
councillor krump so
um i would be supportive of that unless
anyone else has anything they want to
say at this stage
we will move to the vote um i can't see
anyone
looking to type so i think we can do
that
okay um so the forgive me i haven't
sought planning conditions um what i
should do is
uh speak to our case officers and or our
planning manager to see if they have any
suggestions of
conditions for us
who would like to help me with that
uh thank you chairman shall i go first
it's it's tracy we we do have a list of
suggested conditions which my colleague
um louise um can can run through in a
moment
um did you want me to sum up what we
feel the planning issues to be before
members make their vote uh you can do
yeah
okay thank you chairman obviously uh
we've set out in the report
uh the previous site history and the
fact that there have been two previous
class q
um uh notifications bear in mind those
aren't full planning applications to the
authority their notifications on on the
back of that national legislation which
which allows those those conversions to
happen under strict controls
um we do feel that the weightier for the
back position
is the um the the single
dwelling uh class q conversion whereas
the proposal in front of us
is for three open market dwellings uh i
understand what members have
have said in debate but i would
reiterate officers views that we do feel
that the proposal for three open market
dwellings
is is quite clearly contrary to policy
um so we wanted to to stress that for
members awareness before you make your
uh your judgement we've also got two
reasons for refusing in front of you and
the second one obviously relates to the
fact that there is a
considerably large um cartilage attached
to the dwellings which would
um potentially be allowed
for uh sort of ancillary domestic usage
outbuildings and so forth um so officers
would obviously
summarize as you can see in the report
that we do feel in our perspective that
it's quite a clear-cut reason for
refusal
nevertheless if members take a different
view uh perhaps uh louise can just
run through a list of suggested
conditions uh for members consideration
yep happy to do that now um so list of
conditions wording of which we'd
requested to be delegated to officers
um so standard three years um
second for uh development to be carried
out in accordance with the approved
plans
third conditions submission of material
samples
of which would include a stone sample
panel given we've got stone here
um four would be um submission of a hard
and soft landscaping scheme condition
five would then be the retention and
replacement planting
um condition six a restriction on the
timing of demolition works which was
requested by county council ecology
condition seven and eight land
contamination and remediation conditions
condition nine
uh drainage so uh disposed of surface
water and file sewage
condition ten provisional visibility
displays 11 provision of radius turnouts
12 submission of access surfaces in
details 13
the removal a restriction on the
position of any new gates and also
the removal of the existing gates into
the site condition 14 provision of
bicycle storage condition 15
provision of a refuse bin storage area
um condition 17 provision of bins within
the site condition 18
water butts and condition 19 electric
vehicle charging points
would also propose a further condition
and that would be for the removal of
permitted development rights part 1
classes a and e
and part 2 class a
we feel the reason for this is that
given the scheme is contrary to the
policies within the development plan and
has only been supported due to the
existence of a prior approval fallback
officers consider the use
of this condition to restrict permitted
development rights to be justified
uh moreover development approved under
classic queue uh does not benefit from
permitted development rights and the
proposal here also
substantially increases the guarding
areas above which
uh already have consent under the prior
approval um
and that's it with the conditions
okay thank you i'm happy with that
councilor parry um i think you wanted to
come in and speak as well
yes thank you chair and thank you louise
um i was only going to make sure that we
had the removal of permitted development
rights
and that has now been uh has been added
so
i'm perfectly happy with those
conditions um which are very
comprehensive
and appropriate marvelous thank you
that's the crap you second did i presume
you're happy as well
yes mr chairman thank you marvelous
thank you i'm going to
seek guidance from our uh solicitor as
well just to make sure that he's happy
that i follow procedure properly and we
can move to a vote
yes chair happy marvelous thank you very
much in that case the proposal is to
grant
application i'm gonna get the number
first uh application twenty zero
three three nine five ful agricultural
building court fields in butler's
marston
i will go first uh council richards four
thank you councillor fleming council
fleming against
[Music]
council iv councillor dixon
councillor dixon against
against councillor paris
councillor parry four that's five four
and three against thank you very much
olivia in that case committee resolves
to grant application twenty
zero three three nine five f12 for the
reasons given
thank you very much members um i
admitted from
um uh before i started the application
to tell you that councillor kendall has
regrettably had to pass his apologies
he's had an absolute nightmare with his
technology
so he apologizes and we'll make sure
that it's all sorted before our next
meeting
olivia if you could please note in the
minutes that he has given his apologies
okay right let's move to our next
application which is
application reference 20 0 3 3 5
four full that's new house farm
birmingham road in paslo
our presenting officer is amy flute amy
are you there and if you are
please whenever you're ready go ahead
thank you chairman let me just share my
screen with you
okay
okay can i check that everybody can see
that please
certainly can lovely thank you chairman
so the application site donated by the
black dot
is an existing agricultural building um
to the west of the a3
400. the application site edged red
is within an open countryside location
and the site is washed over by the green
belt
planning permission is sought for the
erection of a barn style dwelling to
replace an existing building with extant
class q consent for residential
conversion to a single dwelling
the proposed site block plan indicates
the position of the proposed dwelling
which will be in an alternative position
by comparison to the dwelling approved
by class q
consent which is denoted by the hatched
outline
on the comparison plan to the right
existing plans of the current building
can now be seen
the proposed dwelling would be of a
similar size and scale to the existing
building
the building will be reorientated the
proposed materials would reuse and match
the stone used on the existing building
and introduce metal cladding
sorry i think my computer's just frozen
there we go
um the proposed elevations are now being
shown
against the proposed elevations approved
by the class queue
the class q approval is at the top with
the proposed elevations um
seeking consent under this application
below
this image is taken from the access
drive looking in a south
easterly direction towards the existing
building
sorry my computer's just um taking a bit
of time to move to the next slide
no problem take as much time as you need
thank you chad cool now it's gone too
far
here we go um this image is looking in a
westerly direction
towards the existing barn new house
farmhouse can be seen
behind the barn
sorry i'm just going to come out of the
big screen a moment to see if it will
um if i can show it in a different view
no problem looks like we need to upgrade
your computer for you
i think it's just the internet to be
honest so
um the western elevation of the building
um
can be seen um this image is taken
within the garden of new house farm
and finally the relationship of the barn
with new house farms front and side
elevation can now be seen
chairman there are updates on the update
sheet tonight please
um the proposal represents inappropriate
development in the green belt and the
proposal is also contrary to locational
requirements prescribed by policies
no other harm has been identified it is
considered in this case
that there are very special
circumstances to outweigh the identified
harm
chairman the recommendation is to grant
the application as detailed within the
committee report
thank you thank you very much amy okay
we will
move to our first speaker who is
councillor lee from william
how's elite are you there you may need
to press star and six to unmute your
keypad
hello hello councillor lee good evening
and welcome
can you hear us can you i can hear you
uh chairman yes marvelous i think you i
can hear um i think i can hear a live
stream in the background if you wouldn't
mind muting that because it does
interfere and it's also slightly delayed
and so you'd be better off using the
phone that's all right
okay um when you're ready you'll have
three minutes and we'll give you a 30
second warning
and obviously if you can stay on
afterwards we may have some questions
for you otherwise whenever you're ready
you're free to go
uh good evening councillors the parish
council was concerned he said this
application
seeks to demolish a structurally sound
sorry i thought i had
we'll start your time again if you want
to start from the top that'd be great
thank you very much shannon the parish
council's concern is that this
application
seeks to demolish a structurally sound
agricultural building
which is quite capable of conversion and
to rebuild
a reorientated new dwelling the barn is
situated in greenbelt and the
application applicant now proposes to
wreck the new building
having already obtained consent for
conversion
under extant class q and is using this
as a base to justify a new building in
greenbelt
had the barn not existed an application
for new building in a green belt
under planning rules we believe would
have been refused
we do not believe that demolishing and
to rebuild is the intention of the class
q regulation
in fact it's very much based on
refurbishing existing agricultural
buildings
and bringing them into residential use
the rationale for this proposed
pre-building is predicated on the basis
of very special circumstances
identified in the application which
considers
outweigh what would normally be regarded
as an inappropriate new bill in
greenbelt
the parish council do not believe these
very special circumstances
establish sufficient grounds for
granting planning consent for the
following reasons
one he appears to be no planning
betterment for the local community
in fact the reorientation of a new
building will disturb the existing local
rural setting
in a visually prominent part of the
pasture landscape
the betterment identified by the
applicant appears to only benefit the
applicant by offering more privacy
from the other dwelling on site two
the reorientation of the new build will
not only reduce the size of the existing
garden
resulting in less green open space
but increases the hard standing area for
vehicle access
and the associated draining issues any
deliberate loss of green belt open space
is unacceptable the very special
circumstances reviewed in regarding
energy efficiency
can easily be achieved by converting
existing bar to meet current standards
this does not necessate a new build to
achieve this
the applicant proposes to use similar
materials to make the new
building appear as the original so why
demolish the existing building which
converted
to the same standard as the new bill in
conclusion
chairman the parish council considers
that the applicant's special
circumstances should not justify
council preference would be to go back
to the fallback situation
uh under clark extant class q thank you
council lee thank you very much for that
let me see if our members have any
questions for you members could you
indicate in the chat
if you would like to ask a question to
counselor lee please
i'll give you a couple of seconds to do
that
i'm not seeing much movement so i'm
going to take that as a nose counselor
lee
thank you very much for your
contribution this evening you are now
probably best place to continue to watch
on the live stream and you can hang up
your handset but thank you again for
your contribution
thank you very much chairman thank you
okay we will move
to our next speaker who are the
applicants mr and mrs
uh schilvok i hope i've pronounced that
correctly
um can you hear me okay you may need to
press star and six to unmute your keypad
thank you care we can hear you fabulous
so you have three minutes and we'll give
you a 30 second warning before your time
is up whenever you're ready do please
feel free to start
okay good evening members my husband and
i have lived in stratford for almost all
of our lives
our children are enjoying growing up
here too both attending local schools
they're very close family with our
parents siblings and their families
living in the town and surrounding area
a mother-in-law lives next door to us a
new house farm is our forever home
my mom and dad now in their late 70s
have lived in stratford for 40 years and
they recognize that as they get older
living next to us would be extremely
beneficial in fact
a very real need in light of the recent
lockdowns
the granary or grandparent as our
children call it
is right next door to us and already has
permission under class q to be a home
for my parents
mum and dad will be able to remain
independent but close by
the granary was constructed in the 20th
century it's a simple utilitarian
building of no historical or
architectural interest
a point agreed by the officers as you
can see from the accompanying photograph
the stone is arranged in a modern
stretcher bond pattern and the top part
of the building is modern metal sheeting
the internal timbers are all modern and
have no special character
our application is simply to reorientate
the granary
which as the planning officer has
confirmed causes no harm
and has many benefits over fast q
permission which is the real alternative
the south facing living rooms that the
reorientation creates
will significantly increase natural
light so important for my mum who
suffers from seasonally affective
disorder
which is greatly relieved by getting as
much sunlight as possible
heating bills will be reduced by facing
south and there will be much better
insulation than is viable under the
class queue
in terms of preserving sufficient
internal room space
and the cost this will result in a lower
carbon building with a better long-term
energy efficiency
the reorientation will improve the
immunity for the granary and our house
by avoiding any mutual overlooking each
home will have its own private space
which as pointed out by the planning
officer is better for housing stock
generally and for future occupiers at
some distant time
this area of land will be changing use
and under the class queue
so the reorientated building will be
less impactful to the green belt
the reorientated building will be of
identical size and scale to the existing
building
and will be very similar in appearance
reusing some of the existing stone and
materials
keep the story of the building alive
strongly believe that this application
is so much better than the class q
alternative
no precedent is being guessed by this
application because the building will be
very much the same as that already
permitted under class q
just reorientated no harm has been
identified from reciting the building
there are only benefits meeting a local
needs giving our family a better quality
of life
i really do hope that you'll be able to
support this application thank you for
your time
and thank you very much for your
representation there members do we have
any questions
please for our applicant please indicate
in the chat if you do
i'm seeing lots of shagging heads and
not very much movement so i think that's
it no questions at all so thank you very
much for your contribution um
again you're probably best place to
watch the the live stream and you can
hang up your handset
now but thank you okay
so our next speaker is registered as uh
councillor shenton although as we've
noted uh in the update sheet councillor
shenton has
um removed his uh or withdrawn his
objection
and moved to a no representation i can't
see him in our meeting now so i'm going
to assume that he is not going to be
speaking tonight and we can move
straight to points for clarification
so members do we have any points of
clarification for our officer
please indicate in the chat if you do
[Music]
i will just give you a couple of seconds
looks like that's gonna be a no okay in
that case let's move to debate who would
like to kick us off
cancer jennings right as you know
i like bomb conversions um
and this will still remain a bond
conversion
and just to keep me happy it's a one for
one
um so um
we're just talking about re
reorientating a barn
there to there
i can see and i i really can't see any
problem with this at all
and i'm happy to propose that we go with
the officer's recommendation
to to accept this to grant it
marvelous thank you very much councillor
jennings uh council dixon next please
thank you chairman i'm happy to uh to
second that proposal it's nice to see
a situation whereby we've got a a
wonderful one
as opposed to the the previous
application and it's
really is uh very good to see that even
the dimensions are practically identical
as well
obviously there's no reduction in size
on this one whereas
the chair said that obviously the last
one was uh
a reduction in volume um which i can't
find but uh
that never mind a situation this is a
straight one for one
so yes happy to second thank you
councillor dixon it was mentioned during
one of the
uh representations um councillor fleming
next please
ah thank you chair um as i am a
member of the climate change panel on
council
it was nice to hear that the lady said
that um
she will be improving the the insulation
and the power consumption and
it would be an environmentally friendly
better uh better proposition than what's
there
if they did the conversion so i'm happy
to support that on that basis thank you
thank you councillor fleming councillor
mills please
well thanks jim thatcher i was uh
following bill fleming
all i can say is i think this is great
um and i'll support this application
thank you
chen marvelous thank you very much um i
can see no one else has indicated
they're designed to speak so
we've got a proposal it's been seconded
let's move to a vote the proposal is to
grant in line with the officer's
recommendation and the details in the
update sheet which includes
the additional uh condition um i will go
first
council richards four thank you
councillor fleming
council fleming four councillor crump
council councillor dixon council dixon
four councillor eddon
that's unanimous chair marvelous thank
you very much uh olivia um
as i was moving us to the vote um i
noticed our planning manager would like
to make a point so before i confirm uh
the uh the vote i just asked uh tracy to
come in and make that point
uh thank you chairman yes you beat me to
it actually i was going to point out the
extra condition in the update report
and maybe just to make a general point
that uh hopefully members will see from
the two recommendations on this item and
the previous one that officers always do
make a recommendation based on the
individual merits of the case
uh rather than uh you know policy
for policy's sake so hopefully members
will see that
uh that we do uh take applications uh in
the fullness
of uh of all the issues that they
actually raise
marvelous thank you very much tracy i
think it's a given that we do recognize
that
uh but thank you for making that point
um okay so um
we have therefore committee of resolved
to grant application 203354
ful uh in line with the officer's
recommendation and
the update sheet okay um we have our
speakers in for our next item so we will
go straight in
um it is uh application reference twenty
zero two
five eight zero ful that is land
at uh pandike street in southern
i can hear my own voice so i'm assuming
that um
uh one of our speakers uh has the live
stream running in the background if i
could ask them to mute the live stream
and follow one on their phone
the live stream is slightly delayed and
it does also cause us some issues when
we can uh we're getting feedback from it
so if you could please follow on your
phone
or handset that would be great um our
presenting officer for this is joe brook
so joe if you're ready
please do feel free to start thank you
chair
uh let me just get up the presentation
uh i take it everybody can see that
certainly can good the application site
is located in the physical confines are
so from as indicated by the black dot
before you
the site itself is located to the south
of pendleton street
as indicated by the red line boundary
the site extends beyond the rear gardens
are number one and number three pendle
street
and to really the property is situated
on pound way the site is further
encompassed by dwelling houses to the
north south
west and north west with varying design
scales masses
and heights adjoining the application
site to the southwest is a large
industrial storage and office building
the site is relatively flat and
presently enclosed by two meter high
close
boarded timber fence this is a google
earth for the site
um pretty much follows that sort of
line so this is penndot street
residential developments this is the
industrial office building i was
referring to
these are a small retail shops and this
is pound way and
leads all the way back up to pendle
street with all residential properties
surrounding it
the application is seeking permission to
react to two-story dwelling
with an attached one-half story side
projection to the east elevation
the over the dwelling reset is 7.4
meters to ridge with an overall
development footprint of 111 square
meters
the dwane is supposed to be of mach 2
design with oak
timber detailing and rendered panels
with plain clay top roof tiles to the
front elevation
the rear elevation will have one single
gable finishing timber weatherboarding
and red brick
the application is also proposing a
two-page detached
garage set at three meters to ridge
just go back to the elevations because i
shot forward
so this is the elevations as detailed in
the report and as i've just described
front elevation from the machine to sort
of finish
west elevations that's the um one story
sort of element
one and a half i guess you could sort of
argue uh and this is the weatherboard
into the south elevations the rear
elevation which will be facing a long
pound way
these are the floor plans as indicated
by the elevations three bedrooms
dining room utilities and so forth
and this is the two bay garage which is
three meters to ridge
and about two point two meters to um
eaves i sat on a report
so this is a sight so you can see
penndot street so
beyond the car park which is a reference
in the report the dwelling would sit
roughly there sort of on an angle
looking out this way
you can see these are the developments
to the rear of it
this is the application site in a minute
and i will show you some more photos in
two seconds
so you can see it's very sort of overrun
and bit direct at the minute these are
the ones to rear it would sit
pretty much in line with these dwellings
here
this is powering way development to the
rear that's the rear eye application
site
this is pendant street itself that's one
and two three pending street and
dwellings are further along penndot
street
this is also part of the uppercase site
and just make out the agricultural
industrial building and office which
i'll show in two seconds
and there you go the industrial building
and office
so this is the street scene along
penndot street
so you're facing coming into sorry from
that way this is where the conservation
area ends literally on them
one and two three penndot street and
leads upwards
this is then facing back out towards the
south from round the boat
so obviously as detailed and report the
flats with the garages underneath
the industrial unit which is to the west
of the site and
the retail outlets that i was describing
now this is a long pound way and i'll be
honest i did take it from google earth
it showed the best
way to show the whole site because you
can see
the industrial building there this is 29
of the dwellings
to the rear uh so the site itself would
sit just behind there
this is further along which shows some
of the architectural detail into the
site situated to the left
this leads back on penndot street going
up there
and that's the end of the presentation
uh i sat in the officer's report
just go back to the application before
you see reference it again
i sat in the office report the
application is considered to comply with
all policy requirements and is
considered to respect the existing
vernacular australian built form
in terms of soil scales mass height and
materials
as well as the southern conservation
area while ensuring adequate living
meetings for all future residents
officer recommendation is therefore
approval i would also
request that you have a look at the
update sheet and you will note there is
some supplementary comments from wc
highways
in respect to why they offered no
objection to this application
thank you fabulous joe thank you very
much for that
we will go straight to our first speaker
who is david bruno um
mr bruno can you hear me okay you may
need to press start and 6 to unmute your
keypad
start and 6 to unmute mr bruno hello
good evening i can hear you
welcome
you have three minutes uh we'll give you
a 30 second warning before your time is
up otherwise
it's over to you good evening members
and thank you this opportunity to speak
i've got apologies from absence from
ruth hogan and james milo have put in
and stand by their objections but are
uncomfortable with public speaking my
objections of course
concerns are over development road
safety and privacy
i know that from the committee report
that some but not all previous
applications have been taken into
account and used to justify the current
position
however it is failed to take into
account county applications 1703
468 out which was now on application for
two dwellings at number one penndot
street
this application was for the same piece
of land and i acknowledge that the
access was three metres to the left and
proposed application
but the observations are important and
relevant to the current application
the observations of town council's
objections on the 23rd march 2018
are as follows as previously southern
town council objects to this proposal
for the following reasons and dutch
street is a difficult street to
negotiate
parked cars create a one-track road and
additional access from potentially six
cars and service vehicles entering and
leaving would be dangerous despite
visibility space
also this development of the back garden
lanes contravenes policy cs5 design
and distinction as being set back and is
not sensitive to the existing street
scene
and is not in context with the locality
it is over development
i'm just trying to clean your
understanding
you're muted
forgive me i think we've just lost mr
bruno i've seen someone trying to get
back in again mr bruno have you just
rejoined us
mr bruno can you hear us
it looks like we may have just lost uh
mr bruno um
forgive me uh or bear with me and i will
pull up
his representation and i will read it to
you forgive me for a second when i
get i'm afraid i am going to start
from the beginning because i didn't get
uh exactly where mr burnham cut off so
uh good evening and thank you for this
opportunity to speak my main objectives
and course were concerned for into two
areas
over development of a garden backland
site
road safety and visibility i note from
the community report that some but not
all previous applications have been
taken into consideration
and used to justify the current position
however it has failed to take into
account planning
application 1703 468
out which is an outline application for
two dwellings at one penndy street
this application was for the same piece
of land and i acknowledge that the
access was three meters to the left of
the proposed application but the
observations
are important and relevant to the
current application the observations of
the town council objection were as
follows
previously southern town council objects
to the proposal for the following
reasons
vending street is a difficult street to
negotiate depart cars create a one-track
road
and additional access and potentially
six cars and service vehicles entering
and leaving would be dangerous despite
visibility displays
also this development of back garden
land contravenes policy cs9
design a distinction as being set back
uh it is not sensitive to the existing
street scene and
it and is not in context with the
locality
it is over development i'm yet to
ascertain or understand the
uh inconsistency forgive me the
inconsistency of how the town council
goes from this position
to one of no representations regarding
development of this land and access to
this site
i consider that the current application
addresses none of the previous concerns
regarding development on this site
the conclusion of the highways
department who had several
objections regarding parking and
visibility were as follows this is on
30th of january 2018.
the highway authority does not consider
that much scope exists to overcome the
issues raised regarding visibility given
the constraints of the site
i failed to understand why other
previous applications and findings have
been taken into account
and used to justify the approval when
the one that had proper scrutiny and
objections
regarding over over development and
matters of highway safety
has been admitted from the committee
report these are not my observations but
the opinion of the relevant departments
on development and access considerations
and to emit these findings portrays an
unfair representation
of the site and its uses and this issue
sorry uh the proposed access
has a high wall fence on either side on
a different
a difficult road to negotiate and should
be subjected to the same scrutiny
this current application highways report
and committee report makes no reference
to visibility
and this matter should be given serious
consideration and proven to meet the
relevant requirements
before approval is given that
is the excuse me when i get back to the
screen i need to be in
uh that was uh mr bruno's speech
verbatim um
i believe mr bruno may well have managed
to get back into
uh the meeting mr bruno can you hear me
you may need to press star and sticks
again to unmute
hello mr bruno is that you uh hello
there sorry about that
technical issue that's quite all right
it does happen um
while you were rejoining us i have read
out verbatim the uh the script that you
you've very kindly sent to our committee
services so
um rather than go through that again uh
what i'll do now is open up to our
members to see if they have any
questions for you if that's okay
so members do you have do you have any
questions for mr brunette
i'm not seeing many people moving at the
moment
i'll take that as a no okay in that case
mr bruno thank you very much for your
contribution sorry for the
the problems with connectivity um you're
probably the best place now to continue
to watch the live stream on your device
and you can hang up your handset when
when you're ready
but thank you again do you have any
questions
okay we will move then to our final
speaker on this item who is councillor
crump
uh councillor crump you have five
minutes we'll give you 30 second warning
whenever you're ready please start yeah
won't need the five minutes yeah
i know time is tight i'll be short and
sweet like me
i've had several complaints about this
application
so i felt this is needed this did need
to come to committee for determination
as opposed to an officer's decision um
it does have some merits to be
fair but i've also got some concerns too
obviously beauty
is in the eye of the beholder and not
sure how in keeping it is within the
area
uh agree that the site can accommodate
the garage so i've got no
particular concern about that if
approved i would like to see
robust hard and soft landscaping
conditions
and it is disappointing that the rear
gable end is
only 18 meters from number nine number
29
pound y less than the 21 meters in the
spd
i still have still some concerns about
the garage height and scale
causing some loss of light and being
overbearing to neighbours
but i'm sure that could be overcome i
have got one point
that i do need to make and i'm not sure
where the officer is aware of it this is
with my county council hat on
penndot street is the job center for
our area i'm sure council parry is aware
of that and
been used very successfully and it's
been
designated a covered vaccination route
so works in that route
uh are limited um uh
very strongly by the county council
permits are not approved at the moment
until
august or it's really difficult to get
approval so
um i'm not sure how how prove it is to
plan him but i
just needed to mention that so
everybody's aware of that so
um apologies for that but it is vital
and that needs to be taken because is
national importance the vaccination
center
um the route is used by many uh to go to
school
um coming through the underpass passed
paying line
paying away and we've got southern prime
um mary's primary school just around the
corner and not too long ago there was a
an accident fortunately not too serious
but
the traffic just come off the a425 the
domentry road off the roundabout
and either goes up the doventry into
davinci street
or wishes off into penndot street at
significantly high speeds so that is one
of my main concerns
uh i do agree that a remedial strategy
condition
is vital and it again it must be robust
and strong
uh and enforced properly um so
that's all i've got to say on the matter
so i promise to be brief
and got in within my time thank you good
man thank you very much
members do we have any questions for
cancer crump
please indicate in the chat if you do
i'm not seeing much movement
and there's nothing coming in the chat
so counselor crap thank you very much
um let's move two points for
clarification for our officers
uh there have been two key points i
think they've drawn out over the
representations that we made so um could
we please have an understanding
of uh first of all application 1703468
um the outline application for two
dwellings has that been considered
and if not should it have been and if
it's not and should have been then why
hasn't it been
and the second is the impact of this
covered vaccination route
is it a material planning consideration
i said i feel it's not
uh but if we could get some guidance
from from one of our officers that'd be
great
uh yeah thank you chair firstly in
regards to the 2017
application the honest truth is that it
has been considered
i appreciate it i've just looked at my
report and it wasn't registered in the
applications at the top
but to confirm that i have gone through
it the application was withdrawn
so at no point was there a determination
made it was for two dwellings and as you
can see in the update sheet to make sure
that all aspects was considered i
requested
why if highway still comes this
conclusion that access is safe enough
down there with visibility's place
highways have come back with that and
that's why i see on date sheet
um so it has been considered i often
apologize
it wasn't referenced in the table within
the report but all the applications on
that site
have been considered and like i will
reiterate there was no decision on that
it was withdrawn so although there was
paris council objections and so forth
you have to appreciate on this one all
aspects have been considered
and we have no objection from all the
statutory council teams
um in respect to the covered vaccination
fundamentally no the main reason being
is because there's nothing in policy or
legislation right this moment in time
that would say it is uh also you have to
appreciate we've got three years
implementation on the site that doesn't
even mean it has to be completed it's
just
a commencement and therefore one day
hopefully this whole scenario will be
over and we won't have to go
to vaccination places to get jabbed
so we have to consider a long-term
prospect that
hopefully in a year's time this won't
even be something that we
even refer to okay
that's very clear thank you very much
and council parry has a question for you
as well
council parry
thank you i notice in the conditions
there is there are
it is being pro proposed for a
construction management plan
um could if we're minded to
um approve could that just also
incorporate
um the impact of the nearby schools
um well the construction manager to be
honest
yeah i don't think that'll be an issue i
can certainly highlight it with highways
and the impact and so forth and
the whole purpose of the construction
management plan is try and make
construction
as easy as possible during that phase so
i can't really
finish yeah but but also
from the construction management
perspective there could be some
consideration to southam clinic which is
delivering the um vaccination center as
well
because there are there is quite a bit
of diversion traffic and
there's a lot more traffic movements
than there would be normally
um so if that just could be incorporated
in the construction management plan i
think it would be helpful
if we're minded to approve thank you
uh thank you casper perry i think that's
a fair comment councillor mills has a
question for you as well please thanks
mr chairman um hi joe
um joe um the world member he's got
concerns over around visibility and road
safety
can you show me on the plans where the
entrance of the if if we do go for grant
where this site would be
because it is a busy junction there i
know that
yeah sure let me just um gather the
presentation again
so red line barringers you can see comes
off there
and that's where it will be going in and
out because that's literally the access
point so i'll go to the photos as well
which makes it slightly easier
yeah i know it's the street scene gives
you a really good perspective so it's
coming off there
it's coming off there so yeah so you see
that's the car park area that i've shown
earlier
there yeah do we know sorry joe do you
know how far that is from the roundabout
because it's uh oh actually no don't
worry
don't worry don't worry that that's
that's fine thank you
thanks joe thank you very much that's
all thank you councilman thank you joe
um
it looks like we haven't got any more
questions for you joe so we will move to
the debate who would like to kick us off
councillor jennings first in
yeah and to me this is all about uh
about the highways and access
issue um highways
don't object uh they've got they have
they've offered
put three conditions on it but that's it
um therefore i'm happy to go with the
officer's recommendation
and i'd like to propose that we grant
this application
okay thank you very much counselor junks
um as anyone else i would like to
have an input to the debate before i
speak
i can see a couple of people typing so
i'll see who gets there first counselor
dixon's first
uh i would simply second the uh grant
recommendation proposal by councillor
jennings
okay thank you very much councillor
parry next please
thank you chair um whilst i i
subjectively feel that the design isn't
actually
doesn't necessarily fit in with the
character of the street scene and the
surrounding properties
i can't see a planning material reason
to refuse so i'll be going support
lovely thank you very much cancer mills
next please yes well i was going to say
that it doesn't
really fit in and there is a concern
about
um visibility but i think that's far
enough away
uh from that roundabout so yes i think
i'll be going for the
support in this one thank you mr
chairman thank you very much counselor
fleming please
i'd go along with the others and say
that uh
you know it's not exactly what i would
choose to build there if i had a choice
but
having said that i'd rather have that
house behind me than
the mess that's there at the moment um
and again no planning reasons to refuse
so i'll go along with the officer's
recommendation
thank you fabulous thank you very much
councillor fleming um we did speak
briefly during
the uh points of clarification about
adding in or at least
i think a note or some consideration to
the job center
and uh the schools as part of the
construction management plan
can i uh safely assume that uh councilor
jennings
that is part of your proposal um and
councillor dixon that is part of your
second
answer jennings first no problem at all
council dixon
agreed marvelous okay in that case let's
move to a vote uh so
the proposal is to grant application
twenty zero two
five eight zero ful along with that
additional uh
note for the construction management
plan uh i will go first councillor
richards
four thank you councillor fleming
johnson fleming four councillor dixon
council dixon four councillor
just dropped out on mine or on
everyone's counts reading four
there we go thank you councillor hensha
seraphin
councillor serving four councillor
jennings
kessler jennings four councillor mills
council mills four
and councillor parade councillor parry
full that's unanimous chair
thank you very much olivia in that case
committee resolves to grant application
twenty zero two five eight zero f2l
for the reasons given uh we will move
them to our
final uh application of the evening
which is application twenty zero
three one two three ful that's 12 hulk
road in studly
our presenting officer is charlotte dix
charlotte i'll give you a second to uh
to get yourself ready and everything on
screen
um i can hear myself again uh getting
some feedback so if i can ask our
speakers please to
mute their live streams and to follow
the meeting along with their handsets
there is a delay
and we get a lot of feedback from uh
from the live stream so if you please
follow it on from your handsets that
would be
helpful charlotte over to you
thank you chairman i will just get the
presentation up on the screen
so you should be able to see that now
certainly can lovely thank you very much
so the site is indicated on the map by
the
black circle the application site is
within the build superior boundary and
residential area of studly
this slide shows the application site
edged in red
the site consists of a semi-detached
dwelling on a wide plot with a detached
garage close to the eastern boundary
this is a full application for a
staggered single and two-story side
and rear extension this slide shows the
proposed ground floor extension and
demonstrates that the extensions would
be
set back from the front elevation
retaining a 1.4 metre gap to the side
this image shows the proposed first
floor plan two bedrooms and an ensuite
bathroom are proposed at first floor
level
this image shows the proposed front
elevation and the left hand side of the
screen
and then the proposed side elevation as
viewed
from the east on the right hand side
the set down of the ridge height of both
parts of the extension are visible on
these plans
this photo shows the site and the
attached property the application
property is on the right hand side
and the existing detached garage on the
site can be seen on the right hand side
of the photo
this photo shows the rear of the sights
facing west towards the rear of number
10 halts road the adjoining property
and shows the existing rear extension on
this property
this photo is taken panning round to
show
the wide plot and the existing detached
garage
and then the rear and side elevations of
number 14
holds road
this photo is taken from the front of
number 14 whole road facing back towards
the application site which is visible
here
this photo shows an existing two-story
side extension
on number eight holt road which is two
doors away
this photo is taken from across the road
looking back towards the application
site which is visible centrally in the
photo
again you can see the two-story side
extension on this part of the photo
that's number eight whole road
then this photo shows the mixed street
thing
and we are facing west along holt road
the application site is labelled and
this is the site here
so just to clarify there's no updates
within the update sheet
and officer recommendation is to grant
planning permission subject to the
conditions and notes found on page 61 of
the agenda
thank you very much chairman fabulous
thank you very much charlotte we will
move straight to our first speaker who
is councillor adrian smith of studly
parish council councillor smith can you
hear us okay
you may need to press stone six to
unmute your keypad
just to reiterate that start and sex
will unmute you
and hopefully we'll be able to hear you
i'll give you a couple more seconds
councillor smith are you are you there
i'm i'm on a mobile phone do you read
over
uh we do read now thank you very much
roger that
uh so you have three minutes uh we'll
give you a 30-second warning
whenever you're ready do feel free to
start okay thank you chad good evening
chair good evening ladies and gentlemen
and thank you for the opportunity to
speak this evening
representing studly parish council and
the reference for the application 12
hold road studly we wish to sustain our
objection
um on on a number of points and
initially
the uh the extension is not subservient
to the primary building
the semi-detached property is circa 1900
and as you know this is an amended
application and it
presents as little difference from the
original application
which was rejected uh and i think a
significant point amongst this
is that the uh the extension presents as
27 larger than the actual primary
building
or the original building it's believed
by residents
an examination by the parish council
that it is not an extension
and is an attempt to construct a further
dwelling
you will note the application is for a
five-bedroom house
parish plan and the pending neighborhood
plan does not call for any five-bedroom
houses
although we should treat the application
in isolation on on its own merits
the case office has referred to number
eight halt road
where an extension of a similar scale
was refused
this was represented and approved when
its size and scale was reduced
i feel the parish council would support
an application for a smaller extension
or development
in keeping with the area and in summary
to be brief the objection is based on
the following
over development of the site negative
impact on the street scene
and the extension although set back by
comparison to the original application
the scale mass and bulk is out of
keeping
with the street scene and the other
dwellings in the road
i would therefore sustain the objection
from the parish council
and suggest respectfully that the
applicant
reapply with something of a smaller and
acceptable size
to the local residents that's my summary
and i
thank you for the time and thank you for
listening
casa smith thank you very much uh if you
bear with us and i will see if our
members have any questions for
you members could you please indicate in
the chat if you do have a question
i'll give you a couple of seconds
i'm not seeing a huge amount of movement
so it looks like you've covered all
bases councillor smith thank you very
much for your contribution this evening
you're probably the best place now to
continue to watch on the live stream so
you can hang up your handset but thank
you
for your contribution with your good
night
thank you okay we will move to our next
speaker
who is uh mr colleen summers um speaking
on behalf of
neighbours and residents mr summers are
you there can you hear us okay
you may need to press star and six to
unmute your phone
star and six
mr summers hopefully you can hear me
just to reiterate
i can hear you now yeah there seems to
be some delay on on the technology
tonight so apologies for that and thank
you for your patience
um you have three minutes you have three
minutes we'll give you a 30 second
warning
um otherwise whenever you're ready do
feel free to start
thank you very much good evening mr
chairman and members i thank you for
allowing me to read this statement which
represents the views
of neighboring residents who object to
the proposed extension amendment
you as a planning committee have to make
important decisions
and in order to do so you need accurate
information on which to base those
decisions
however it's quite disturbing that the
report from your case officer
appears to be extremely misleading
firstly the report states that the
proposal is subservient to the original
main dwelling
this is incorrect the footprint of the
proposed extension
still needs to be reduced by at least 30
percent
for it to be considered subservient
secondly the report states that
adjacent properties number 8 and 6 have
similar extensions to this proposal
this is also incorrect the extensions to
numbers 8 and 6 are definitely
smaller in footprint to the original
main dwelling just making them
subservient
thirdly the report states that the
distance between number 12
and number 14 will be 11.4 meters
this two is incorrect 11.4 meters
is the measurement between the walls
facing each other
that will be furthest apart if you
measure between the walls facing each
other
that will be closest this gives you a
distance of just six
meters a huge difference to 11.4
so these three points in the report
distort the true picture
one mistake could be allowable two
mistakes questionable
but three mistakes totally unacceptable
what what is further disc disconcerting
is that the design still lends itself to
splitting the property
into two dwellings at some point in the
future this will downgrade the joining
number 10 from being a semi-detached
to a terraced house for information
number eight applied to do this in the
past and that application was turned
down
furthermore the car parking hard
standing area is likely to cause
flooding to number 10
due to the incompatibility of the levels
of
road footpath and damp course
finally whilst neighbours object to the
amended plan
they are not against the building of an
extension providing
it complies with current rules and
regulations and is subservient
to the original dwelling so please do
not rely
simply on the information case officer
report as i believe it's misleading and
inaccurate
and please give due consideration to the
additional points made
before reaching your decision thank you
very much
one and all mr thank you very much for
that if you bear with me and i'll see if
our members have a question
for you we have one from councillor
parry councillor parry
thank you chairman and uh good evening
to the local resident i just wondered
obviously you're speaking on behalf of a
number
of of neighbours whether you were all
familiar with the stratfor district
council
extending your home um
planning guide um which which is still
policy and adopted by the core strategy
but was first put forward on
2008 where it highlights
um side extensions and rear extensions
and what considers to be subservient i
just wondered whether you were aware of
this particular document
uh i'm aware of the document but i can't
speak for any of the other neighbours i
cannot speak on their behalf thank you
okay there are no further questions
coming forward from our members so
mr summers thank you very much for your
contribution this evening again you're
probably best place to watch the live
stream on
on your device and you can hang your
hand set up now but thank you again
thank you very much okay we will move
to um mr mark seely uh who is our
applicant either our applicant or
speaking on behalf of our applicant so
mr seeley are you there
again you may need to press star and six
to unmute your keypad
hello can you hear me i can indeed uh
welcome good evening you have six
minutes
and again we'll give you a 30 second
warning uh whenever your friends
whenever you're ready feel free to start
perfect thank you
so uh holt road has six semi-detached
houses uh each of the semi-detached
houses are now
unique after being extended only our
house number 12 is the same as the
original construction
aim has always been to build an
extension base on the current street
scene
it is our intention to follow the brick
construction of the property the same as
number eight and number 10
and not render the exterior as the other
remaining properties have done
by copying existing approved
developments on the same street
and keeping the carriage of the property
we feel that this is in keeping with the
street scene
of the six semi-detached houses on halt
road two already have a developed area
the same size as our proposal and one
has a developed area
larger than our proposed design covering
the entire width of the plot and has a
full depth extension
that is not considered subservient we
took note of the comments made by
objectors and submitted a revised plan
based on the other dwellings in the road
and feel we have achieved what's been
asked of us
we designed the main side extension to
be set back on the front elevation and
lower the ridge height to be subservient
we reduce mass and bulk and may summit
the extension into a single story
this has the approval of the stratfor
planning officer
as we understand the 10-year plan for
suddenly paris council
commencing 2017 under the housing
development section
states that developments featuring
family homes to be generally be
prioritized over those containing one or
two bedroom flats
a family home is what we are trying to
create the sole
aim and design is to build a family home
so that my elderly mother will have
ground floor
living accommodation for when mobility
becomes an issue in the future
and that she will have her own space and
remain in her own home to be looked
after by her own family
in line with government thinking whilst
also meeting the needs of our involving
family
design will also provide an extra
bedroom for us to continue to foster a
young person with additional needs
who has been a long-term match with us
for the next nine years
we feel the development is in line with
the current street scene and don't
believe it to be over developed
compared to already existing
developments when also considering the
size of the plot
it is set within we believe it is in
line with everything that stratfor
planning office team acceptable against
planning policy
and we have followed their guidance and
we were happy to amend everything 100
as requested we have always been open to
change and amend our plans but there has
to be a fair limit on what is expected
of us
when we're at a point where our design
is following and within planning policy
but also provides the development we
require for our family home
we cease any further amendments we have
a letter support the application from
number 14 our neighbours who if anyone
on the street
will be affected the most by any changes
to our property we hope you will
consider our application favorably and
we thank you for your time
mississippi thank you very much for that
members do we have any questions for our
applicant
please you'd indicate in the chat if you
do
it's not seeing a huge amount of
movement so i'm going to take that as a
note
mr silly thank you very much for your
contribution again if you'd like to
follow on uh the live stream um you're
probably best place to do that you can
hang your handset up now so thank you
very much
thank you okay our final speaker of the
evening
is uh councillor eden chancellor thank
you for your patience
whenever you're ready you've got five
minutes we'll give you a 30 second
warning over to you
uh you'll be pleased chair that mute may
well not be working
very well tonight um okay thank you very
much
um this is a a curious one that i've
thought long and hard about
um and eventually i've come down on the
side of the neighbors and the parishes
view
um as much as i think it's slightly
over developed i do think that it's
bringing about an almost
allowable terracing effect that could be
carried on up and down the street
uh and predominantly i agree with their
observation that it isn't subservient at
all
it's of almost equal size again and
whilst the officers report says that it
could be
read as subservient i don't really share
that reading of the outcome
um i'd also urge members to clarify
regarding the the gap of 15 meters
to number 14 becoming only 11 meters
that was mentioned by the parish council
as well i believe
or i'm not sorry the uh the resident uh
the plans show
over doubling in width with the existing
property reading at around four and a
half meters wide so this observation
appears technically incorrect to me
however i'm sure that could be cleared
up
um i therefore conclude that in my
opinion this is over development
of the site and would ask that you
refuse it on such a basis along with the
subsequent negative impact on the street
scene and
and it's pigglety but very much open
look and feel
that's that said i'll leave it to
members good judgement on this one
um i struggled with it myself so thank
you very much
thank you very much counselor um do we
have any uh questions for our ward
member please
members indicating the chat if you do
i'm seeing lots of
uh vacant expressions
some [ __ ] some shaking of heads no in
that case
no no no questions for you casa eden
thank you very much
um we will move in two points of
clarification to our officers
uh caster odin has already raised one so
i shall i shall bring that
uh forward now the uh the gap between
this uh property and
uh number 14 is indicated at 11 we're
told it might be six could you give us
some
some guidance on that please charlotte
yes of course if i can uh just bring up
the
plan that would help
so the distance from this part of the
extension
to number 14 would be approximately 11
meters
but moving back so the
this part of the two-story extension
would actually reduce down to
approximately seven meters from the side
of number fourteen
so that's where that difference comes in
okay so it's a point of measurement
uh rather than anything else and you do
say seven meters in your report as well
so
okay thank you very much um question
from casa dixon please
thank you chair uh charlotte can you put
that uh
floor plan back up again please because
essentially
it was a situation whereby we've heard
lots of comments from the parish council
and the spokesman for the residence uh
basically advising us that they don't
think much of your report
so i'd like to give you the opportunity
to address their comments if uh if you'd
like to
yes um in terms of the impact on the
street scene and the character you've
got preparing
and their reference to the fact that
this extension is much larger than the
other ones
down the street etc the and the over
there
claiming it's over development etc um
and the risk et cetera so i certainly
looked at that floor plan and it's a
it is a large extension is the lat is
the lao is the lounge the original
and bedroom one all extension yes so the
lounge is the original
um so that's the original side elevation
of the properties this would be
the two-story extension along here and
this part and then the single-story rear
extension at the back there
so in terms of the assessment the
officers have carried out
um we considered that due to the um
we've obviously assessed the massing and
the scale of the development
um and due to the fact that there is a
um
set down of the roof line for the two
story aspects here
and the setback of the uh the extension
on this part as well
along with um the reduction in the width
as part of the amended plans
um again the gap to the side and
obviously looking at all the
existing development in the streets it's
a very eclectic mix of different
properties along colt road
um so taking into account all of those
aspects
we considered that the the extension
would be subservient to the original
property
this part of the extension here would
only be visible
as you are immediately in front of the
dwelling itself
um due to the the street scene you
wouldn't have a glimpse of that until
you are
almost upon the property um and
and just looking at all the other
extensions within the street we do
consider that the size and scale
would be subservient to that to the
original property
thank you charlotte certainly obviously
the ridge height and the stepping back
does make it subservient
but the sheer volume looks indeed that's
double the size of the house
thank you thank you very much casa parry
next please
thank you chair um i just wondered
whether the
officers could advise that if um
because looking at that side element
there is there appears to be
on that particular proposal on that
elevation
there appeared to be a an exterior door
um i know the parish council raised
their concern
about it could become another residence
i notice in our extending
your home um document
april 2008 that
that should sort of that makes reference
to granny flats or granny accommodation
um it shouldn't be self-contained
and therefore it is it is suggested
there a planning condition
will often be used to prevent the use
of this type of accommodation becoming a
separate residence
if we were minded to grant would it be
possible to add that condition
and would that be considered reasonable
in view of the
the volume and scale and also that the
applicant did highlight that it it was
more than likely to be used
for um a more elderly member of the
family
in the future
all right thank you councilman harry um
in terms of
um whether the development would be
considered as ancillary to the main
dwelling um as as part of an extension
it has been assessed that this would be
um you know
in scale with existing property and it's
having a
side door is a very traditional form of
you know other entry points into the
house
so it's not something that has concerned
officers um
if members were minded to support the
application
with um in view of that that concern we
we could look at
adding another condition onto the
approval which would be
um which would ensure that the
development was always
ancillary to the main use of the the
dwelling um rather than being used as a
separate dwelling house
and thank you very much both i i was
going to ask a similar question along
those lines i would assume that one
would have to submit a full planning
application in order to separate the two
of separate
houses so is it is it necessary to have
that additional
uh condition i completely understand the
sentiment but i question whether it's
absolutely necessary
yes i mean officers would raise concerns
in terms of whether it would be
necessary
because as you say you would need to
submit a planning application for the
creation of a new dwelling on that site
okay thank you um tracy you've said
you'd like to make a comment on that
thank you chairman yes i've just been
looking at the uh the internal layout
and it does seem that the
there is a fleet a free flow in terms of
the
the access into that certainly if it was
a free standing granny annex in the
garden i think we'd be looking to tie
the two by condition
uh i think seeing its internal floor
space it's not absolutely necessary
so whilst members could add a condition
on if they feel it necessary i think
officers would say in this circumstance
we don't need to do so
but reassure members that if it was
separated and operated separately
in practice yes it would need planning
permission as two separate dwellings and
our enforcement powers remain in place
to investigate if that was happening
marvelous thank you i share that view
uh counselor seraphin please
thank you chair uh charlotte you keep
saying it's subservient to the existing
building
can you explain that to me okay
yes of course um so when we're assessing
subservience we do assess um a range of
different factors
and so we'd look at the size the scale
the width the height
and the overall masses in terms of the
original property
and we would be looking to make sure
that any extensions were subservient to
the original property so that they
that the original property is the
dominant feature within the the design
of the scheme
and the any extension doesn't unbalance
that
that appearance of the dominance of the
dwelling
but to me it looks that the volume of
the extension
is far greater than the existing
dwelling
in terms of the the overall width uh the
width would be greater than the original
part of the
property if you take into account the
two-story side extensions plus the
two-story ensuite
extension as well um as i mentioned
we do take into account a range of
different factors when we're looking at
the subservience
and whether that would be harmful in
terms of the impact on the street scene
and views of the property as well
in this case whilst the extension is um
larger than some other extensions um
we would consider that it wouldn't be a
harmful addition to the property or
within the street scene
yeah because uh it was referred earlier
on to number eight which has got a
an extension um
containing four bedrooms
i'm concerned you might be moving into
debate and we shouldn't be debating with
the officers
but i do apologize okay charlotte thank
you
thank you councillor dixon next please
thank you chairman um it was really to a
certain extent
uh with tracy's commenting that uh the
officers wouldn't
uh uh recommend the uh condition
because you would need planning
permission to turn it into a separate
dwelling
um how would you be able to a know that
it had been
used as a separate dwelling would not a
condition
highlight it to any potential purchaser
that there was a
restriction and it couldn't happen
whereas
if there is no restriction um
would they seek an or seek planning
permission but
uh that might be debate as well chairman
i'm not sure it is debate if i'm honest
um i mean we can certainly debate it uh
tracy charlotte do you want to come back
on that i have a view but i'll leave it
to you as our
our guiding experts chairman shall i try
and help assist the assist members there
um again i'm just referring back to the
layout plan in front of me
it's a um
it's a ground floor bedroom with uh with
an ensuite
i don't think there's anything so
intrinsic in the internal layout in
front of us that would uh
render the proposal um unacceptable in
planning terms
or so worrisome that it would be
necessary or
realistic to put a planning condition on
as i say
members are entitled to take a different
view on that
if it was for example the internal
layout completely reconfigured so that
the dwelling were
split into two um uh we would be
reliant on um any advice given to us
by sort of local people or the parish
council or so forth if they felt that it
was not being operated in accordance
with the planning permission
and as ever in the event of an
investigation if complaints were
received
then our enforcement powers again are
something we could uh utilize to
investigate that but i see nothing in
that layout that would intrinsically
give me concern
that this isn't going to operate in an
ancillary fashion
lovely thank you very much we have no
further questions
for our officers or points of
clarification so let's move into the
debate
who would like to kick us off councilman
i think councilman mills was first note
forgive me council jennings was first
council jennings
okay thank you chairman this is a large
site
it's and it's going for a large
extension i don't see a problem with
that
um i look at it and i think yeah i can
absolutely understand where the office
is coming from
um in my view as well i think it's
subservient
um i don't think we need to put on a we
wouldn't need to put on a condition
um about it being separated
um they wouldn't be able to sell it this
list would be flagged up if they're
trying to do
his two houses it's not an issue um
it's very much a mixed street scene um
i can see no material planning reasons
to go against the officers
recommendations
i'm happy to propose that we grant this
fabulous thank you councillor jennings
councillor mills please
thanks mr chairman yes i i did go and
visit the site
um and at the present time
they're quite nice attractive
semi-detached
uh houses um i have to say
um i don't i look at this i know there's
one
been just developed along the uh a few
doors down
but this development is huge it's even
yeah
it's larger than i thought it was going
to be um looking at the plan so
i i personally don't like it um i think
it is over development for the site so
uh thank you very much mr chairman
okay thank you councillor mills um no
one else has indicated that desire to
speak at the moment so i will i will
dive in at this point while members uh
put anything in the chat if they want to
um i'm going to uh second castle
jennings uh proposal i think the report
is robust and the responses that we've
been given
to questions that have been raised by
the the uh uh by our speakers tonight
have also been robust
um i do think it is subservient to the
main dwelling there is the space to
build
uh what has been proposed um i don't
think it's an overdevelopment of the
site there is still spacing and gapping
between the houses
there is evidence of similar extensions
being approved along the same street
so i can see no reason why no planning
reasons why we would go against officers
recommendation
so um we have it proposed we have it
seconded council
uh parry has indicated a desire to speak
so councillor perry
um thank you chair i was just going to
i'm i'm proposing to support this um
proposal um i feel the
um the layout and the design that's
being put
forward is actually very much in keeping
in extending your home
because the ridge levels the frontages
is all set back
just by a brick width type of thing that
the ridge of the roofs are set back
um and it does conform to the the
guidance that's set out
in our in our policy document that was
adopted by the call strategy
and therefore i can't see a planning a
material planning reason
um to refuse this because of the size
and scale
of the actual um site itself
and therefore it's not over development
of the site thank you chair
thank you very much councillor um in
that case there's no further
members registered to speak or have
questions so let's move to a vote we
have a proposal to grant in line with
the office of recommendation it has been
seconded by myself
i will go first council richards four
thank you
councillor fleming that's a fleming four
cliff ramp there's the comfort
councillor dixon councillor dixon four
councillor hunter seraphin and
friendship seraphine against
jennings councillor jennings former
against marvelous thank you very much
olivia a committee therefore resolves to
grant application twenty zero
three one two three ful that is 12 hole
road studly in line with
the officer's recommendation members um
there's no urgent business so it remains
for me to thank you all for your efforts
and contributions this evening and
particularly to thank
all of our officers um all those that
have spoken and those that have been
helping behind the scenes thank you
so much for your help in getting this uh
committee
um sorted good night everybody thank you
thank you hopes everything goes fine for
you and family peter